I'm Jennifer Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind the scene stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hello! Hey, welcome back! Welcome back from Thanksgiving. off-slates. Hello.
我是珍妮弗·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正为你带来终极的《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有当事人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室娇娃。你好！嘿，欢迎回来！欢迎过完感恩节回来。没有日程安排。你好。
Hey, welcome back. Welcome back from Thanksgiving. We hope everybody had good meals and good times. Yes, with friends and family. Some people do friends giving. One of my favorite thanks-givings was a friends giving. It was my first year in Los Angeles. I couldn't afford to fly home to see family.
嘿，欢迎回来。欢迎过完感恩节回来。我们希望大家都吃得开心，过得愉快。是的，和朋友及家人一起。有些人会过“朋友感恩节”。我最喜欢的感恩节之一就是一个朋友感恩节。那是我在洛杉矶的头一年。我买不起回家看家人的机票。
Yeah. So me and my other friends who were in LA, we got together and we had a Thanksgiving. My friend Luda, she's Russian, she brought this Russian vodka. We all got so hammered. That's a friend's giving. It was so fun. I actually just found a picture of us. Recently it came up in my memory. Really? Yeah. I love that. Yeah, we had traded it. You know, Josh, he bought me the most insane thing last year for Thanksgiving. And he was like, this is going to be a tradition now. You're going to have to wear it every Thanksgiving. I was like, babe, what is it? Okay, you know, I'm always cold. And I always want a cozy onesie.
对。所以我和其他在洛杉矶的朋友聚在一起，过了一个感恩节。我的朋友露达，她是俄罗斯人，她带来了这种俄罗斯伏特加。我们所有人都喝得烂醉如泥。这就是朋友感恩节。太有趣了。我其实刚刚找到一张我们的照片。最近它在我的回忆里弹出来了。真的吗？对。我太喜欢了。对，我们把它换了。你知道，乔斯去年感恩节给我买了一件最疯狂的东西。他说，这以后将成为一个传统。你以后每个感恩节都要穿它。我说，宝贝，是什么？好吧，你知道的，我总是很冷。而且我总是想要一件舒服的连体衣。
I'm like, babe, get me a onesie, get me a cozy onesie. Okay. Lady, it's a turkey. A turkey onesie. And first of all, it's a one size fits all. So it's enormous. Do you eat in it? Is it weird all day? No, I can't, it's like wearing a giant blanket.
我说，宝贝，给我买一件连体衣，给我买一件舒服的连体衣。好吧。姑娘，它是一只火鸡。一件火鸡连体衣。首先，它是均码的。所以它大得离谱。你在里面吃东西吗？整天穿着它感觉怪怪的吗？不，我不能吃，这就像穿着一条巨大的毯子。
I can't eat in it, but I do put it on. Well, I've only done, this is my second year. Okay. I don't know what the tradition of this turkey onesie's gonna be, but I told him, here. Well, I've only done, this is my second year. I don't know. I don't know what the tradition of this turkey once he's going to be, but I told him, here's what I'll do, because he thinks it's so cute. I put it on and I watch the Macy's Day parade in my turkey once.
我不能穿着它吃东西，但我确实会把它穿上。好吧，我只做过，这是我的第二年。好吧。我不知道这件火鸡连体衣的传统会变成什么样，但我告诉他，给你。好吧，我只做过，这是我的第二年。我不知道。我不知道这件火鸡连体衣的传统会变成什么样，但我告诉他，我会这么做，因为他觉得它太可爱了。我穿上它，在我的火鸡连体衣里看梅西感恩节大游行。
Okay. And then you know, we get the food prep going, but I don't wear it to the actual Thanksgiving dinner. What is it that Josh thinks this is so funny? I look like a tiny tiny turkey. Do you watch football? Yeah, football's always on. So when I got into football, I was dating a guy who was from Detroit and you know Detroit plays everything's giving. And the Cowboys. Yes, now I'm married to a Dallas man. Yeah. Now I'm a Cowboys fan.
好的。然后你知道的，我们开始准备食物，但我不会穿着它去吃真正的感恩节晚餐。乔斯为什么觉得这东西这么搞笑？我看起来像一只小小的火鸡。你看橄榄球吗？对，橄榄球一直在播。所以当我迷上橄榄球时，我正在和一个来自底特律的家伙约会，你知道底特律在感恩节有比赛。还有牛仔队。对，现在我嫁给了一个达拉斯男人。对。现在我是牛仔队的球迷。
Oh, yeah. Yeah. So Cowboys, everything's giving. You got to work the meal around it. Half of my family's from Texas, lady. Yeah. It's always cool. What am I saying?
哦，对。对。所以牛仔队，感恩节。你得围绕它来安排饭菜。我有一半的家在德克萨斯州，姑娘。对。总是很酷。我在说什么呢？
I know. Of course. Well, listen, we have a really exciting show for you today. I don't even know what to say about it. It's maybe one of my favorite episodes we've ever done. Jenna and I are in love with this interview, you guys. I'm sorry, it's an interview, but it was so wonderful. Would Jenna you tell everyone?
我知道。当然。好吧，听着，我们今天为你准备了一个非常精彩的节目。我甚至不知道该怎么评价它。这可能是我做过的最喜欢的剧集之一。珍娜和我爱死这次采访了，伙计们。我很抱歉，这是一次采访，但它太棒了。珍娜，你来告诉大家吧？
Well, we got to sit down with Zach Woods. As you know, Zach played Gabe Lewis on 52 episodes of The Office. He was on from season six to season nine. We talk all about it. We talk about his entire time on the show. And other things. Here's the thing. He's just so interesting and he's so smart and funny.
嗯，我们有机会和扎克·伍兹坐在一起聊天。如你所知，扎克在52集《办公室》中饰演了加比·刘易斯。他从第六季一直演到第九季。我们聊了这一切。我们聊了他在剧中的整个经历。还有其他事情。事情是这样的。他实在是太有趣了，而且他既聪明又滑稽。
And we would be talking about the show. And then he would throw you and I like a curve ball question. Like a deep like question about what it means to be just human and alive. Like, yes's so fun. Oh, I just can't wait for everyone to listen to this interview. I just love it. Well, you guys, Zach is currently working
我们会聊到这部剧。然后他会抛给你一个像我这样的刁钻问题。就像一个深刻的问题，关于身为人与活着意味着什么。就像，太有趣了。哦，我简直迫不及待地想让大家听听这次采访。我太喜欢了。好吧，伙计们，扎克目前正在
on a new stop motion animation series called In the Know. He's the co-creator, the director, and star of the show. And Greg Daniels is one of the executive producers. So you know this is going to be good. The show premieres on peacacock in the New Year, so be on the lookout. Yeah, we'll share about it in stories, but you know what?
制作一部名为《知情者》的全新定格动画系列。他是该剧的联合创作者、导演和主演。格雷格·丹尼尔斯是执行制片人之一。所以你知道这一定会很精彩。该剧将于新年孔雀频道首播，敬请期待。对，我们会在动态里分享，但你知道吗？
I think we take a quick break and get to this interview because it's so fantastic. You're gonna love it. And the second half, dare I say, is even better than the first. It keeps getting better and better. Here it is. Hello, Zach. Hello. Hello, Carol. Wonderful to see you.
我想我们该休息一下，直接进入这次采访，因为它太棒了。你会爱上它的。我敢说，下半场甚至比上半场还要好。它越来越精彩了。节目开始。你好，扎克。你好。你好，卡罗尔。很高兴见到你。
How wonderful to see you and you. Should we tell people we've actually been chatting off mic for like 30 minutes? Oh, seriously, we've been talking for half an hour, but we decided we should probably get to the podcast. Yes. They literally said we're going to do a big fake hello, and then you immediately call it on yourselves. You're giving away our secret.
见到你和你们俩真是太高兴了。我们要不要告诉大家，我们其实已经在没有麦克风的情况下聊了大约30分钟了？哦，真的，我们已经聊了半个小时了，但我们决定还是应该开始录播客。是的。他们直接说我们要假装热情地打招呼，然后你们立刻就自己戳穿了。你们把我们的秘密泄露了。
So, right. I'm going to do an office man, office ladies podcast, right? I tell the stories behind the office ladies podcast. Okay. I'll be like Russian dolls. Oh my gosh. So, you listen to office ladies, and you break down our podcasts. Right. And I'll have you guys on to talk about the podcast when you're talking about this. This might be a genius idea. Well, we're going to kick things off
所以，对。我要做一个办公室男，办公室女士播客，对吧？我讲述办公室女士播客背后的故事。好吧。就像套娃一样。哦，天哪。所以，你听办公室女士，然后你剖析我们的播客。对。然后我会邀请你们来聊聊你们在聊这个时的播客。这可能是一个天才的主意。好吧，我们要开始了
with the question we ask all of our guests to start, which is how did you get your job on the office? So good question. Alison Jones, who you guys both know, was like a fairy godmother to me. Like she for people who I mean, I know you've talked about her on the show, but she was the casting director for the show and like basically American comedy for a decade and more, right? And she brought me in to her office, which was in Gower Studios, right? I guess they used to shoot. I love Lucy and stuff. Wow. Right, isn't that right? I think so, yeah.
我们问所有嘉宾的第一个问题是，你是怎么得到《办公室》这份工作的？真是个好问题。你们俩都认识的艾莉森·琼斯，就像我的神仙教母一样。就像她对于人们——我的意思是，我知道你们在节目中谈论过她，但她是该剧的选角导演，在过去十年甚至更长时间里，她基本上就是美国喜剧界（的代表），对吧？她把我叫到她的办公室，就在高尔工作室，对吧？我猜他们以前在那里拍《我爱露西》之类的。哇。对，是这样吗？我想是的，对。
It's like one of these old Hollywood things. It's got like plaques everywhere. Right. And like plaster and it just feels like, you know, whatever. You can like, it's like where you can imagine like Clark Gable's stumbling into there after he like killed someone with him and be like telling his publicist like,
这就像是好莱坞的那些老古董之一。到处都是牌匾。对。还有灰泥，感觉就像，你知道的，随便吧。你可以像，就像你能想象克拉克·盖博在用什么东西杀人后跌跌撞撞地走进那里，然后对他的公关说，
bury it. But anyway, uh, yeah, for Clark Gable. Sorry, Barrier. But anyway, poor, yeah. Poor Clark game. Sorry, Clark Gable, you've probably never killed anyone. I'm sorry. I just feel like I,
把这事埋了。但不管怎样，呃，是的，为了克拉克·盖博。对不起，埋了它。但不管怎样，可怜的，是的。可怜的克拉克·盖博。对不起，克拉克·盖博，你可能从来没杀过人。对不起。我只是觉得我，
you know, like old Hollywood stars were always killing people and telling their publicist to cover it. Barrier, get rid of it. Yeah. She was just some girl. No one's gonna know. Yeah, anyway, but got distracted. Alison Jones.
你知道的，就像老好莱坞明星总是杀人并告诉他们的公关掩盖它。埋了它，除掉它。对。她只是个女孩。没人会知道。对，不管怎样，但分心了。艾莉森·琼斯。
Alison Jones. So I remember meeting with her, and I'd done this movie called In the Loop, and she'd seen it, and she brought me in for a meeting, and I really hadn't done anything, except for this one little independent movie, and she talked to me for like an hour, and then at the end of it, she just went,
艾莉森·琼斯。所以记得我和她见面，我拍过一部叫《灵通汪洋》的电影，她看过，她叫我去开会，我其实什么也没做，除了这部小独立电影，她跟我聊了一个小时左右，然后在结束时，她突然说，
I'm gonna help you, which is such a wild thing for someone to say in Hollywood. And then even a wilder thing to mean and follow through on. And then she got me a meeting with Greg Daniels and Paul and they just gave me a part on the office, which is a show that I had been like obsessively watching. I felt like I won a contest. Like, you know what I mean?
我要帮你想办法，这在好莱坞对某人来说真是一件疯狂的事。然后更疯狂的是她是认真的并且说到做到。然后她帮我安排了和格雷格·丹尼尔斯以及保罗的会面，他们直接给了我《办公室》的一个角色，这部剧我一直像着了魔一样在看。我觉得我中了大奖。就像，你知道我的意思吗？
Like you win a raffle and you can do like a walk on on like a TV show. Like I felt like it was so bizarre to me that she almost threw it like to a suspicious degree where it's like, who's gonna jump out and say, gotcha or. Right. Yeah. Or is she gonna like, am I gonna get a call in here or Allison Jones is like throwing a palm in one of my enemy's faces.
就像你赢了一张彩票，然后你可以在一个电视节目里客串。我觉得这对我来说太离奇了，她甚至以一种可疑的程度抛出了橄榄枝，就像，谁会跳出来说，抓到你了，还是。对。是的。还是她会像，我会接到电话吗，或者艾莉森·琼斯就像是在我敌人的脸上打了一拳。
It's like time for payback. Yeah. You know exactly. Yeah. And then yeah. And then I just got this part. And then I moved into this house in Echo Park, where it was a basement, and I'm tall,
就像是时候报复了。对。你知道的，完全正确。对。然后，是的。然后我就得到了这个角色。然后我搬进了回音公园的一间房子，那里是个地下室，而且我很个高，
and there were these rafters. So I had to constantly duck. Like, I couldn't, it was the ceiling was too low, so I was constantly doing these, like, kind of body rolls around my living room. And I was, somehow she got wind of this, and she was like, oh, I have an empty condo in Beachwood Canyon, which I'll give to you for a song basically.
还有这些横梁。所以我不得不经常低头。就像，我不能，天花板太低了，所以我不得不在我的客厅里不断地做这种，有点像身体滚翻的动作。然后，不知怎么的，她风闻了这件事，然后她说，哦，我在海滩wood峡谷有一套空置的公寓，我基本上可以便宜租给你。
And then she gave me this beautiful condo to live in for like very low rent, where they used to house, it was like a dormitory for starlets back in the, it was like the MGM gals would be there. And in the basement there was a beauty salon where they had to go through the works before they could go out into the world because they didn't want anyone seeing like the MGM girls looking less than their best basically.
然后她给了我这套漂亮的公寓，以非常低的租金让我住在那儿，那里以前住过人，就像是过去星光熠熠的宿舍，就像米高梅的姑娘们会待在那里。在地下室有一个美容院，她们在走进现实世界之前必须在那里经历全套流程，因为她们不想让任何人看到米高梅的女孩们看起来不是它们最好的状态，基本上。
So I said effectively an MGM girl. Thanks to Alison Jones, but I'm being long-winded. I'm a little nervous because we're starting to be less long-winded, but I will just say Alison Jones, I will never be able to adequately express the difference that Alison Jones made in my life, professionally, residentially, personally, just like that woman just like tap me with her magic wand and gave me my life.
所以我说我实际上是个米高梅女孩。多亏了艾莉森·琼斯，但我废话太多了。我有点紧张，因为我们开始变得没那么啰嗦了，但我只想说艾莉森·琼斯，我永远无法充分表达艾莉森·琼斯在我的职业、居住、个人生活上对我产生的影响，就像那个女性就像用她的魔法棒轻触了我一下，给了我我的生活。
So, you know, in LA, basically. I mean, we feel the same way about Allison Jones. Yeah. I had a general meeting with her and she sort of did the same thing. It was like one hour meeting, hey, I like you. I think you're talented. I'm gonna help you out.
所以，你知道，在洛杉矶，基本上。我的意思是，我们对艾莉森·琼斯也有同样的感受。是的。我和她有过一次例会，她差不多也做了同样的事。就像一个小时的会议，嘿，我喜欢你。我觉得你很有天赋。我要帮帮你。
And then just called me in for years, for little bit parts, and then eventually, how lucky am I that the person who decided to help me was hired to cast the office? That was just my good luck. Yeah, you know, because then she was like, well, I'm gonna have you meet on this new show, The Office. So it was the same thing.
然后连续好几年打电话叫我去演一些小角色，最后，我是多么幸运，那个决定帮我的人被雇去为《办公室》选角！这纯粹是我的好运气。是的，你知道的，因为后来她说，好吧，我要让你去面试这个新节目《办公室》。所以是一样的。
And I've heard people tell this story about Alice and Jones many, many times. It's crazy. And she has this kind of like flinty new Englander quality where if you try to tell this to her face, it's just like, it's like shining light on a vampire. I mean, she just, she refuses the accolades, right? That's right. Yeah. That's right.
我听过很多人讲过很多次关于艾莉森·琼斯的故事。这太疯狂了。她有一种尖刻的新英格兰人特质，如果你试图当着她的面这么说，这就好比，就像把光照在吸 vampires（吸血鬼）身上一样。我的意思是，她就是，她拒绝赞誉，对吧？没错。是的。没错。
She can't tolerate. It's just like, that's been my experience anyway. Where you try to like look her in the eyes and be like, thank you. Yeah. She's like, no. That was fine. You have homemade cookie I just made. She always says like delicious cookies.
她无法忍受。反正我的经验就是这样。当你试图直视她的眼睛并说，谢谢你。是的。她会说，不。那挺好的。你想要我刚做的自制饼干吗？她总是说有美味的饼干。
Right. She just feels like that awesome warm ant that's gonna look out for you. It's true. Allison, we love you. I love you. And my eye, if you haven't gathered it. Besides in the loop, which I remember
对。她给人的感觉就像那个很棒的、温暖的阿姨，会照顾你。真的。艾莉森，我们爱你。我爱你。以我的观点，如果你还没明白的话。除了《灵通汪洋》，我记得
in which everyone was talking about when you came to work with us, it's a great movie. Besides that, what was your background? Like, do you have an improv background? Yeah, I started doing improv at upright systems to begin in New York, and I mostly just thought I was gonna do that.
你来和我们工作时大家都在谈论这部电影，这是一部好电影。除此之外，你的背景是什么？比如，你有即兴表演背景吗？对，我开始在纽约的直立人系统开始做即兴表演，我大部分时间都以为我会做那个。
I remember talking to someone and being like, I just wanna get a temp job and do improv at night. That was eight years of my life. It's fun, right? Did you feel like when you were doing that, did it feel unsatisfying in some fundamental one? No, it was the most fun. It was the most fun. Right.
我记得跟某人聊过，然后说，我只想找一份临时工作，晚上做即兴表演。那是我生命中的八年。这很有趣，对吧？当你做这件事的时候，你觉得它在某种根本层面上很不满足吗？不，这是最有趣的。这是最有趣的。对。
It was the most fun because the job I didn't really care about, I just needed to pay bills so I could go do improv. And then you're with like, you have a community. Yeah, and they all are like-minded. And we were so into it, we were probably really obnoxious. Why I used to teach too, when I was in New York to help, like, I like teaching and also help me survive. But I remember once being in a cab in New York
这是最有趣的，因为我真的不在乎这份工作，我只需要付账单，这样我就可以去表演即兴剧了。然后你和，你有一个社区。是的，他们都是志同道合的人。我们太投入了，我们可能真的很讨厌。为什么以前我也教书，当我在纽约为了生存，像，我喜欢教书，也帮我生存。但我记得有一次在纽约坐出租车
and going past an improv theater and seeing all these adults outside and they were like throwing like imaginary knives to each other or whatever they were doing. Some like warm up. Some improv game. It was so humiliating and so you could not look nerdyer and less cool and these people,
经过一家即兴剧院，看到外面有这些成年人，他们就像是在互相扔假想的刀或者他们正在做的任何事情。某种热身。某种即兴游戏。这太丢人了，而且你看起来不能再书呆子气一点，再不酷一点，而这些人，
I just felt my heart swell in my chest. Like seeing these like grown adults, just like kind of, they look so happy. They were just like being so cringe, so happily, in public, in New York, on the street. I was just like, God bless you guys. Like it's so sweet. Like, I've found it so moving.
我只觉得我的心在胸口膨胀。就像看到这些成年人，只是那种，他们看起来那么快乐。他们只是在纽约街头的公开场合，那么尴尬，那么快乐地。我当时就想，上帝保佑你们。这太可爱了。就像，我发现这太感人了。
I feel like I want to end. I thought it was so perfect when they made the choice to have Michael Scott in an improv group. It's so funny, it's so perfect. It was so perfect. Like I took in rough classes with a Michael Scott. Oh my God, it's mostly Michael Scott. Yeah, oh my gosh.
我觉得我想结束。我觉得他们选择让迈克尔·斯科特加入一个即兴剧团时，真是太完美了。太有趣了，太完美了。太完美了。就像我和一个迈克尔·斯科特一起上过即兴课。哦，天哪，这基本上就是迈克尔·斯科特。是的，哦，天哪。
How much were you told about the character Gabe? Did you know it was gonna be like a long arc? No, I didn't know much. I, it's a pretty foggy memory because I think because it felt like such a, I felt like such a raffle winner where it's like you can be on your favorite show. It created like such a rush of anxiety that like I've never experienced anything like before since like like to be like completely inexperienced as a TV actor and to be thrust into a show where you're like, you know what I mean?
关于加比这个角色，他们跟你说了多少？你知道这会是一个很长的故事线吗？不，我不知道太多。我，这是一个非常模糊的记忆，我想是因为它感觉像一个，我觉得自己像个中彩票的人，就像你可以在你最喜欢的节目里出现。它产生了一股焦虑的洪流，我以前从未经历过，也从没有过，就像作为一个完全没有经验的电视演员，被塞进一个节目里，你会觉得，你知道我的意思吗？
It's just like it was really overwhelming. And I remember like, when I first moved out here right before I started filming, I remember there was like some moment. This is a really crazy, compromising moment. I was at Walmart, first of all, I didn't know how to drive because I've been living in New York. So I had to, like, as an adult man, go to Pennsylvania and have my father retie to me to drive
这真的让人不知所措。我记得，当我刚搬到这里，就在我开始拍摄之前，我记得有那么一刻。这是一个非常疯狂、妥协的时刻。我在沃尔玛，首先，我不会开车，因为我一直住在纽约。所以我不得不，作为一个成年男子，去宾夕法尼亚州，让我父亲重新教我开车
because I was like, I'm gonna be in L.A. You have to teach me to drive. Oh, my God. So my dad taught me to drive, like, some weird, like, little short film or something. And then I remember, when we started shooting, driving terrified me so much that I would show up on set, and my jaw would be so clenched
因为我想，我要去洛杉矶了。你得教我开车。哦，天哪。所以我的爸爸教我开车，就像拍什么奇怪的小短片之类的。然后我记得，当我们开始拍摄时，开车让我感到如此恐惧，以至于我一出现在片场，我的下巴就会紧咬着
that I had a hard time saying words. So I would take CDs, Frank Sinatra CDs, and I would put them in the car and force myself to sing along with old blue eyes so that my jaw would stay open so that I wouldn't show up with like, like rigor mortis face. Yeah.
以至于我说不出话来。所以我拿CD，弗兰克·西纳特拉的CD，我把它们放在车里，强迫自己跟着老蓝眼一起唱歌，这样我的下巴就能保持张开，这样我就不会带着僵硬的面部表情出现。对。
And then, I think before I'd even shot my first scene, being in a Walmart, buying like multiple humidifiers and lozenges and sh** because I was like, I'm gonna lose my voice and then I'm not gonna be able to do it and I'm gonna, I was so panicked and I was worried I was gonna forget my lines. So I was like muttering my lines in a Walmart. For some reason I didn't get a basket.
然后，我想甚至在我拍第一场戏之前，在沃尔玛里，买了一堆加湿器、润喉糖和狗屁的玩意儿，因为我想，我要失去我的声音了，然后我就不能演了，我会，我太恐慌了，我担心我会忘词。所以我一直在沃尔玛里喃喃自语我的台词。不知为什么我没有拿篮子。
So I just had like, armfuls of like humidifiers and lozenges, just like muttering like my lines to myself, like a crazy person. So what I really remember from that time is just the white hot panic of like, oh, you know, like. Were you prone to losing your voice?
所以我只是抱着一堆加湿器和润喉糖，就像疯子一样喃喃自语着我的台词。所以我对那段时期真正的记忆只是那种炽热的恐慌，就像，哦，你知道的。你容易失声吗？
What was this anxiety about losing your voice? I was prone to losing my mind. I was like, I- You in the Walmart. I think it was just like anything. You know, you have like free range. So I'm just gonna feel like anxiety's just like a giant like military helicopter that needs some place to land.
这种关于失声的焦虑是怎么回事？我很容易失去理智。我当时觉得，我——你在沃尔玛。我想这只是像任何事情一样。你知道，你有自由发挥的空间。所以我只是觉得焦虑就像一架需要地方降落的巨大军用直升机。
Yeah. And it was like, Oh, today it'll be landing on the landing pad of like vocal anxiety. Tomorrow it'll be like, whatever that'll, you know, some weird hypothetical thing in a different direction. Yes, yes.
是的。这就好像，哦，今天它会降落在诸如声音焦虑之类的着陆垫上。明天它会像，不管那会是什么，朝不同方向的一些奇怪的假设性事情。是的，是的。
So I don't remember what they told me, but I didn't think I was, I thought it might just be a few episodes and then they gave me more and I was like, wow, that's great. Do you remember your first day on set? Yeah. What did you shoot your very first day? I think the first thing I shot was a, to camera, like one of the interviews.
所以我不记得他们对我说过什么了，但我不认为我是，我以为可能只是几集，然后他们给了我更多，我说，哇，这太棒了。你还记得你在片场的头一天吗？记得。你第一天拍的是什么？我想我拍的第一件事是面向摄像机，就像采访一样。
A talking head. Talking head. Okay. Yeah. That's a good way to start actually because it's just you. No one is dependent on your line for timing. You're not driving a scene. Right.
单人访谈。单人访谈。好的。对。其实这是一个很好的开始，因为只有你一个人。没有人依赖你的台词来掌握时机。你不需要推动剧情。对。
So I think that's actually a really smart way to start. They might have done that on purpose too. What was your first impression coming on the set? Well, John Krasinski directed the episode that I was doing. And I remember something happened on set and it took longer than they were expecting. So I sort of in my trailer just churning. And then they called me to set. And I think John knew that I was kind of like pent up and terrified.
所以我认为这其实是一个非常聪明的开始。他们可能也是故意这么做的。你来到片场的第一印象是什么？嗯，约翰·卡拉辛斯基导演了我正在拍的那一集。我记得片场发生了一件事，花的时间比他们预期的要长。所以我有点在我的拖车里翻江倒海。然后他们叫我去片场。我想约翰知道我有点像上弦的钟一样害怕。
And so he just like even though I'm sure it had been a long day and there was a lot left to shoot, he like let me just improvise a lot in the talking head. I doubt they used any of it, but it just was like, it let me relax. And he was so kind about it. The big thing that I remember, and part of why I was like excited to do this is because I'm not good at staying in touch with people and stuff. But I feel, yeah, that I feel like is important to me to communicate to people who listen to this, which is the level of kindness and hospitality that was extended to me on that show was bizarre. Like, if you're in the late seasons of a TV show
所以他只是，尽管我确信那是漫长的一天，还有很多镜头要拍，但他还是让我随便在单人访谈里即兴发挥了很多。我怀疑他们有没有用过其中的任何内容，但这就像，它让我放松了下来。他对此太友好了。我记得最深刻的一件事，这也是我当时很高兴能做这件事的部分原因，因为我不擅长和人们保持联系之类的事情。但我觉得，是的，这对我来说很重要，要传达给听这个节目的人，那就是在这个节目中给予我的那种善良和好客的程度是不可思议的。就像，如果你处于一个电视剧的后期
that has such a deep bench of amazing characters, and some new person shows up who's gonna suck up even more oxygen, eat up more story time, you know what I mean? It would be very easy to understand if people were not all that receptive to that, especially if it's someone who's like a rookie who's still just like learning about like, okay, what's an eye line? How do I, like, what's a mark?
拥有如此深厚的人物阵容，而且来了一个会吸收更多氧气、占用更多故事时间的新人，你知道我的意思吗？如果人们对这一点并不是那么接受，那是完全可以理解的，特别是如果是一个还在学习诸如，好吧，什么是视线？我该怎么做，什么是标记？
You know what I mean? Like stuff, like just very rookie stuff that I'm having to learn on the go. Like it would be totally reasonable if people had a kind of professional detachment from that person. But everyone was so ostentatiously kind to me. Ostentatious makes it sound bad. Just generous, kind. You guys were so lovely to me.
你知道我的意思吗？就像东西，只是我必须在过程中学习的非常菜鸟的东西。就像如果人们对这样的人有一种职业上的疏离感，那是完全合理的。但每个人对我都表现得如此大方地友善。炫耀性的友善听起来不太好。只是慷慨，善良。你们对我都太好了。
You guys were so sweet to me and inclusive. I remember, I would just sort of camp out at Phyllis and Leslie's desk and watch them like shop for, they were both decorating's desk and watch them like shop for, they were both like decorating their houses and they were like, yes, she was looking for a gate for like, I think two years, she wanted a new, maybe.
你们对我太好了，非常包容我。我记得，我当时就像是在菲利斯和莱斯利的办公桌旁边安营扎寨，看她们像在购物一样——她们俩当时都在布置办公室的桌子，看她们像在购物一样——她们俩当时都在布置自己的房子，然后她们就——是的，她大概找了有两年吧，在找一个大门，她想要一个新的，大概吧。
We looked at every gate possible. I just remember basically, yeah, like gate shopping with Leslie and Phyllis and like they would show me and they would be so nice and joke around with me. I remember Kate Flannery went really went out of her way, Oscar, and not just in a kind, again, not just in a perfunctory professional way,
我们看了所有可能的大门。我只记得基本上，是的，就像和莱斯利还有菲利斯一起去挑大门一样，她们会拿给我看，对我都超级好，跟我开玩笑。我记得凯特·弗兰内利真的对我很照顾，奥斯卡，而且不仅仅是那种客气的、又一次的，不仅仅是流于形式的职业态度，
they invite me to their houses. You guys would include me in social stuff. I just, it was so, it was like the photo negative of what happened to the character Gabe, right? Like, Gabe is like this unfortunate, creepy guy shows up and is immediately and utterly ostracized. It was like, yeah, it was the exact opposite
她们邀请我去她们家。你们会把我纳入社交圈子。我只是觉得，这太……这就像是加布那个角色遭遇的“底片”反过来，对吧？加布就像那种倒霉的、让人有点毛骨悚然的家伙，一出现就被彻底地、完全地排挤。这就好像是——是的，完全相反的待遇
where it was like, oh my God, look at this. Like this group of people is just like so envelopingly sweet. So that was life changing because I was already so fragile and terrified because it was such a new experience. And I wanted so desperately to do a good job and to be met with that kind of generosity of spirit was I think formative for me. I mean, we loved the character Gabe.
那就是，哦天哪，看看这个。这群人就像是被包围着一样无比温柔。所以这简直改变了人生，因为我当时已经非常脆弱且恐惧，因为这是一次全新的经历。我非常渴望能把工作做好，能遇到那种慷慨的灵魂，我认为这对我塑造性格很有帮助。我是说，我们都很喜欢加布这个角色。
I mean, in re-watching, like Gabe has made us laugh so hard, but one of the things we've been most excited about doing this podcast is being able to reconnect with these people that were such an amazing chapter of our life. And you're one of those people. We've talked about you so much. We're so happy you're here. I mean, we still talked about the gift you brought to my Yankee Swap Christmas party, which was a sarcophagus, like jewelry box. It was the gift that everyone wanted. I mean, legend gift. Thank you. I mean, that's like white elephant stuff is like a real source of anxiety, right?
我是说，在重看的时候，加布把我们逗得前仰后合，但我们录这个播客最兴奋的事情之一，就是能够重新联系到这些曾经是我们生命中如此惊艳篇章的人。而你就是其中一员。我们谈起你无数次。你来了我们真的超级高兴。我是说，我们现在还在聊你带到我的白色大象（Yankee Swap）圣诞派对上的礼物，那是一个石棺形状的首饰盒。那是所有人都抢着要的礼物。我是说，传奇级别的礼物。谢谢你。我是说，像白色大象这种交换礼物环节，真的很让人焦虑，对吧？
Because it's like, it feels like a moral spiritual test. So I'm glad that I passed. You passed and I have the sarcophagus. Yes, it's mine. I went home with it. Yeah, I have it on my bookshelf. And it's not cursed or anything, right? Doesn't seem like it. Okay, cool.
因为感觉就像是一场道德和精神上的测试。所以我很高兴我通过了。你通过了，然后我拥有了这个石棺。是的，它是我的。我把它带回家了。对，我把它放在书架上。它没有被诅咒什么的吧，对吧？好像没有。好吧，酷。
Yeah, it seems like it did you. I hadn't actively pursued a curse, but if there's a small sarcophagus, the odds that it has some sort of curse feels pretty eye. It's been good so far. It's doing great for you. It is. It's a heated battle that you won.
对，听起来好像没有。我本来没有刻意去寻找一个诅咒，但如果是一个小石棺，它带有什么诅咒的几率感觉还挺高的。目前为止还挺好的。它对你挺好的。确实。这是你赢得的一场激烈对决。
I also off topic here, but in anticipation of talking to you today, I also off topic here, but in anticipation of talking to you today, I sort of went back through old emails and I have some great photos of you that I sent a long, long time ago to you to probably hold the email, but they're great. They're just of you hanging out on set. So I need to make sure you get those.
我这里也有点题外话，但为了准备今天和你的谈话，我这里也有点题外话，但为了准备今天和你的谈话，我翻了翻以前的电子邮件，我有一些你很棒的照片，是很久很久以前发给你的，你可能还留着那封邮件，但照片真的很棒。就是你在片场闲逛的照片。所以我得确保你能拿到那些。
Oh, I would love that. I would love that. Yeah. Not that I was a creeper, taking pictures of you. We wereer taking pictures of you. There's not my camera in the men's room with like got a lot of candy snaps. No, but I did. I found a few when we were at Shroop farms. Oh, yeah. So I'm going to make sure you get those with grobin. Yes. That's really surreal. I'm going to farm with Josh Grobin and like all these people have been watching for years. It's just such a weird, it's like.
哦，我太想看了。我太想 要了。是的。倒不是说我是个变态跟踪狂，偷拍你。我们是在偷拍你。我的相机没有放在男厕所里拍一堆糖果快照吧。没有，但我的确拍了。我找到了几张我们在施鲁普农场（Shroop farms）时的照片。哦，对。所以我一定要确保你拿到那些和乔什·格罗班（Grobin）的照片。对。那真的太超现实了。我和乔什·格罗班一起去农场，还有所有这些我看了好几年的演员。这感觉太诡异了，就像是。
I'm like, yeah, did someone like dose me with acid and I'm like, just back in my, in my like basement apartment and hell's kitchen having like a weird fever dream? Yeah. So I watched like your first couple of episodes, which must have been so insane because you're talking about being new and everything.
我就想，是的，是不是有人给我下了迷幻药，然后我其实正躺在地狱厨房的地下室公寓里做着一场诡异的发烧梦？对。所以我看了你演的前几集，那一定太疯狂了，因为你刚刚提到自己是新来的，诸如此类的。
Right. So, like, there's the scene where you enter Dunder Mithin for the first time and White is holding a giant tray of hot dogs. And then Aaron and Andy sing the sob race song. Yes. That is so crazy. And then the next episode, you're like wrestling some great Danes and you're talking to Kathy Bates. Kathy Bates. I know. That's crazy. And then the next episode, you're like wrestling some great dames and you're talking to Kathy Bates. Kathy Bates.
对。所以，有这样一个场景，你第一次走进邓德·米夫林（Dunder Mifflin），怀特端着一大盘热狗。然后艾伦和安迪唱起了“赛车”之歌。没错。那太疯狂了。然后下一集，你就在和几只大丹犬摔跤，你还在和凯西·贝茨（Kathy Bates）说话。凯西·贝茨。我知道。太疯狂了。然后下一集，你就在和几只大丹犬摔跤，你还在和凯西·贝茨说话。凯西·贝茨。
I know that's crazy. Why did they tell you that you would be working with Kathy Bates? You know, this is not a satisfying answer, but the truth is, again, it's just this is the sort of like pummeling. The things I do. I felt like I was like being beaten into a happy gang.
我知道这太疯狂了。他们为什么会告诉你，你将要和凯西·贝茨合作？你知道的，这可能不是一个让人满意的答案，但事实是，又一次，这就像是这种……狂轰滥炸。我经历的事情。我感觉自己就像是被打造成了一个快乐的帮派成员。
Or so, like it's just like, it's just like, I don't know, like Kathy B Bates, the office, like, you're in a little line of driving and you're gonna be, like, it just felt like this kind of like word jumble of like, I don't know. What's next? Yeah, I just felt like, like, I don't remember finding it out, like, it's like the fog of war.
或者说，这就好像是……这就好像是，我不知道，就像凯西·贝茨，办公室，你在拍一点戏，然后你就要……这就好像是一堆词语的乱炖，比如，我不知道。接下来是什么？对，我当时就觉得，就像……我不记得我是怎么知道这事的，就像是战争迷雾。
I'm just like, I don't remember. Like, that's very funny. We were so nervous about Kathy Bates being on set. Really? Yeah. What were you nervous about just that she would tell me? Just anything, just like making eye contact. And she was such a presence.
我就觉得，我不记得了。这太搞笑了。我们当时对凯西·贝茨来到片场感到超级紧张。真的吗？对。你们在紧张什么？就怕她会告诉我……随便什么，比如进行眼神接触。她气场太强大了。
And then she was so kind. I think it was just her stature and her body of work. And we had avoided for so long having like these big name actors on the show. And so this was kind of a turning point and it was very shocking. It felt like, you know? Yeah. So my hair colorist had once colored Cathy Bates hair.
然后她人又那么好。我想可能只是因为她的身材气场和她的演艺成就。而且我们有很长一段时间都在避免在剧中有这种大牌演员。所以这可以说是一个转折点，而且非常震撼。感觉就像是，你知道吗？对。所以我的发型师曾经给凯西·贝茨染过头发。
This is just, and he told me this like years ago, you know, and just, you know, when hairdressers just tell you they're lower while they're doing your hair. And he's like, well, you know, I used to color Kathy Bates here. And oh, what a woman. And he just like so admired her and all this. He didn't gossip, but he just did name drop
这只是……他几年前告诉我这事的，你知道的，就那种美发师在给你做头发时会闲聊的那种。他说：“哦，你知道吗，我以前给凯西·贝茨染过头发。哦，真是个了不起的女人。”他简直太崇拜她了，诸如此类的。他没有八卦，但他确实提到了名字
that he had colored her hair. So when I knew she was coming on the show, I had to resist that urge, you know, when like the second I saw her, not to be like, we have the same hair colorist. Hi, I'm Jenna, our hair colorist. He colored your hair. What?
说他给她染过头发。所以当我得知她要来剧组时，我必须克制住那种冲动，你知道的，就是那种一看到她，就忍不住想说：“我们用同一个发型师！嗨，我是珍娜，我们的发型师，他给你染过头发。什么？”
Welcome to the show. I'm so because that you suppressed that. I know that would come just tumbling out of my mouth. I held it. I can't remember for how long I think I made it several days. And then I did finally say, you know, Robert Hickland, Hair Colorist, I think we, I think he, and oh, yes, Bobby, yes, I know him, yes, wonderful guy.
“欢迎来到剧组。”我很庆幸你克制住了。我知道那些话肯定会脱口而出。我忍住了。我不记得忍了多久了，我想我坚持了好几天。然后我终于还是说出来了，你知道的，罗伯特·希克兰（Robert Hickland），发型师，我想我们……我想他，然后，“哦，是的，鲍比，是的，我认识他，是的，一个棒极了的家伙。”
We should be best friends now. Well, that was my next line. So we are clearly best friends then Yes, same hair colorist. Yeah, so much in common. We're on your emergency contact Yeah, exactly. Let me ask you like so because for many people you are that like in other words when people see you Right, it generates the same feelings in them that Kathy Bage generated in you So what is the version like when people come up to you guys and are like, actually, did you know that we shared a, you know, whatever, we stay in the same summer camp cabin
我们现在应该成好朋友了。好吧，那是我的下一句台词。所以我们显然是好朋友了，对吧？是的，同一个发型师。没错，有这么多共同点。我是你的紧急联系人。没错。让我问你一个问题，因为对很多人来说，你就是那个存在——换句话说，当人们看到你时，它在你身上产生的感受，和凯西·贝茨在你身上产生的感受是一样的。那么，当人们走到你们面前说：“其实，你知道吗，我们分享过一个……不管怎样，我们住在同一个夏令营小屋里”时，那种版本是怎样的？
that it, that it, that it, like, does it feel alienating to you when people do that or does it feel nice or does it just depend on the person? Like, well, I guess what I'm asking is like, or maybe is it okay to ask you guys? Yeah, yes, please. What is the version of being approached in a situation like that? Where maybe it's not just like in the airport,
这……这……这……当人们那样做时，对你来说会觉得有距离感吗？还是觉得挺好的？或者这取决于人？我是说，我想问的是，或者说，问你们这个问题可以吗？可以，请问吧。在那种情况下被人接近，会是什么样的一种版本？也许这不只是像在机场那样，
but it's like a situation that has some containment that feels good to you versus the one that feels like, like if you're Kathy Bates, how do you want someone to approach you? Well, I'll say that I just did the Mean Girls movie musical. I play the mom. that I just did the Mean Girls movie musical. I play the mom. Yay! And after I got on the set and I was working, I called Angela and I was like, Angela, we are now like the old lady, like the people, like these kids and the crew and stuff. They're treating me like the way we were around like Kathy Bates or around
而是一个有某种边界感、让你觉得舒服的场景，相比之下，哪种会让你觉得……如果你是凯西·贝茨，你希望别人怎么接近你？好吧，我会说我刚刚拍了《贱女孩》音乐剧电影。我演妈妈。耶！在我进组开始工作之后，我打电话给安吉拉，我说：“安吉拉，我们现在就像是老太太了，就像是那些人……这些小演员和剧组人员之类的。他们对待我的方式，就像我们以前对待凯西·贝茨或者对待
some of these like people who had like the resumes and all that kind of stuff. I'm like it's so weird and it feels like it was so bizarre because I was like, oh, I'm like not at all worthy of your, what do you call it? Like they're giving giving me like, yes, like sort of like, we thank you so much for doing our film and the directors were just like, we can't believe we got you. And I'm like, you can't. I'm like, it's the Mean Girls movie musical. I feel like people are lining up to do this.
那些有履历的前辈时的态度一样。”我说这太诡异了，感觉太离奇了，因为我想：“天哪，我根本不配得到你们的……你叫它什么来着？”就好像他们对我说：“是的，非常感谢你来拍我们的电影。”导演们甚至说：“我们简直不敢相信能请到你。”我说：“你们不敢相信？这可是《贱女孩》音乐剧电影。我觉得人们都在排着队想演呢。”
You're being so overly kind to me. But I do remember that. Like when we would be at an award show, like someone from a television show that we had watched, you get a chance to meet them or they give you an award or something. You're like, oh my God, I can't believe this person. I was like, we're the old timers now.
你们对我也太客气了。但我确实还记得那种感觉。比如我们在颁奖典礼上时，比如能遇到某个我们曾经看过他节目的电视剧演员，或者他们给你颁个奖什么的。你会想：“哦天哪，我简直不敢相信这个人……”我就觉得，我们现在成了老一辈了。
We're the old timers who have been in the biz for a while. And I actually thought it was really cool. I'm still very humbled by it all that, you know, that I got to stop tipping and got to, you know, take the skills I learned from my improv classes and get paid to do something I love. It's still very humbling to me that people watch the show, enjoy the show, wanna watch me be silly or whatever it is. I always feel like I won the lottery.
我们是已经在这一行混了一段时间的老油条了。其实我觉得这真的很酷。对此我依然感到非常感恩，你知道的，我不用再去端盘子了，还能把我从即兴表演课上学到的技能拿来做我热爱的事情并获得报酬。每当人们看这部剧、喜欢这部剧、想看我出丑或者无论是什么时候，我都依然觉得非常感恩。我总觉得自己中了彩票。
So I've still taken it back by it, like what you're saying. I don't think that'll ever go away. I still can't believe I got to do this. I wonder if Kathy Bidts had that feeling. Yeah, maybe I will tell you. Here's an example of when maybe it's not fun or appropriate. I towards the end of my pregnancy was having some pain and they said, okay, let's get you to the specialist for this special kind of sonogram where they can make sure everything's okay. I was having a lot of pain in my pelvis.
所以我对这一切依然感到很震撼，就像你刚才说的那样。我觉得这种感觉永远不会消失。我依然不敢相信我能做这个。我在想凯西·贝茨当时是不是也有这种感觉。是的，也许吧。我来告诉你。这里有一个例子，说明什么时候这种接近可能并不好玩或者不合时宜。我快生的时候身体有些疼痛，他们说：“好吧，我们带你去看看专家，做一个特殊的超声波检查，确保一切都好。”我当时盆腔痛得很厉害。
So I met with this person I've never met before and he's conducting the sonogram. You know, I'm just like laying there and he's like, so is Dwight gonna be stopping by? Oh boy. And I was like, you mean a fictional character? I'm in a television show with it is not the father of my baby? No. I'm coming to you because I have pain in my pelvis. Giving me a sonogram and I'm laying here,
所以我遇到这个人，我以前从没见过他，他正在为我做声纳检查。你知道，我只是躺在那儿，然后他说，德怀特会来吗？天哪。我说，你是说一个虚构的人物吗？我在一部电视剧里，他不是我孩子的父亲？不。我来找你是因为我骨盆疼。给我做声纳检查，我躺在这里，
feeling so exposed. And you asked me, I knew he was like, and he, it's been like 20 minutes. So he'd been holding onto that. And then he was just like, when is Dwight stopping by? So maybe, maybe here's a tip. Like if you're in that situation,
感觉自己毫无遮掩。你问我，我知道他在想，而且他，已经大约20分钟了。所以他一直把这句话憋在心里。然后他突然说，德怀特什么时候来？所以也许，这里有个建议。如果你遇到那种情况，
maybe go bring up the TV show. Medical professionals in particular If you're in that situation, maybe you don't believe in the TV show. Medical professionals in particular should never bring up your celebrity in an exam room. Well, I think that's fair. I think it's fair to do. That's just a good solid boundary. Yeah. You're probably there because you're worried about something.
也许可以提起那部电视剧。特别是医疗专业人员 如果你处于那种情况，也许你不相信那个电视剧。医疗专业人员尤其永远不应该在检查室里提起你的名人身份。嗯，我认为这很公平。我认为这样做很公平。这只是一个很好的底线。是的。你可能去那里是因为你担心某些事情。
Yes, that's right. That's right. You know what? Tell me in the lobby. Tell me in the lobby after work. You need that's right. And that's right. Yeah. You know what, tell me in the lobby. Tell me in the lobby after work. You need to be you. Yeah. Right.
是的，没错。没错。你知道吗？在大厅里告诉我。下班后在大厅里告诉我。你需要，没错。而且没错。是的。你知道吗，在大厅里告诉我。下班后在大厅里告诉我。你需要做，没错。
You need to be who you are and know that that person sees you. Right. You know, I think an analogy that I think of all the time is like, I'm an adult person and I pay a mortgage and I'm raising two children and and all this stuff. And yet all the time I feel like a little bit of like, I can't believe that I am tasked with these adult responsibilities. Like I can't, like young people will look at me and I know that I look like an old person to them,
你需要做你自己，并且知道那个人看到了真实的你。你知道，我想到的一个经常出现的比喻是，我是一个成年人，我付房贷，我在抚养两个孩子，还有所有这些事情。然而，我一直觉得自己有点像，我不敢相信我竟然要承担这些成年的责任。就像我不能，年轻人会看着我，我知道在他们眼里我看起来像个老人，
but like inside, I still kind of feel like a flailing 23 year old who doesn't know what they're doing. So I feel like that's part of it too. Like when people are approaching me and they're like, oh my God, I love your body of work and blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. I still feel like the struggling actor who's trying to make it.
但内心深处，我仍然觉得自己像个不知所措的23岁年轻人，不知道自己在做什么。所以我觉得这也是其中的一部分。当人们接近我，他们说，哦天哪，我喜欢你的作品，啦啦啦啦啦。我仍然觉得自己是个苦苦挣扎、试图闯出一片天的演员。
Like that's never left me. I will say like before I was on the show that blog post you wrote to actors. Yeah, I turned into a book later, yeah. But at that point, I think it was just a vlog post. It was just a blog post, yeah. Advice to actors. It was so, because I'd read that multiple times
这种感觉从未离开过我。我要说的是，在我参演这部剧之前，你写给演员的那篇博客文章。哦对，后来变成了一本书，是的。但当时，我想它只是一篇视频博客文章。它只是一篇博客文章，是的。给演员的建议。它是如此，因为我读过好几次
before ever meeting you or being on the show. Oh my God, I didn't even know that, Zach. Yeah, it was so orienting. I think because a lot of times, I think when people can feel the distance between how they're perceived and how, and their interior sense of themselves, we're describing, I think sometimes people's response to that is to try to identify publicly only with the way they're perceived or something. But I remember for you at that time, to share the flailing, to share the kind of blemishy, angsty,
在我从未见过你或加入这部剧之前。天哪，我甚至都不知道，扎克。是的，太有方向感了。我想因为很多时候，当人们能够感受到他们被感知的方式与他们内心的自我感知之间存在距离时，我们正在描述的，我认为有时人们对此的反应是试图在公众面前只与他们被感知的方式认同。但我记得对当时的你来说，分享那种迷茫，分享那种充满瑕疵、焦虑的，
unsure kind of experience that you'd had was so helpful because it's so isolating to aspire to something. Well, I don't know if that's even true. It's scary to, what am I trying to say? There's a cherry, you know, cherry, John's the actor, actor, cherry, she has this quote that I love so much where she says, the theaters where we comfort each other with our shortcomings, whereas like, I'll show you mine and you'll see yours reflected and then we'll have a night of laughs and catharsis and whatever.
那种不确定的经历是如此有帮助，因为当你渴望得到什么时，会感到非常孤立。好吧，我不知道这是否属实。这很可怕，我在说什么？有个雪莉，你知道，雪莉·琼斯是演员，演员雪莉，她有一句我非常喜欢的名言，她说，剧院是我们用各自的缺点来安慰彼此的地方，比如，我会向你展示我的，你会看到你自己的缺点被反映出来，然后我们会度过充满欢笑、宣泄以及无论什么的夜晚。
In a way, like when you wrote that thing, it's like, not that that shortcomings exactly, but I felt comforted by your vulnerability and by your ownership of that vulnerability because I felt so vulnerable. So seeing like, oh, wow, someone who I admire vulnerability and by your ownership of that vulnerability, because I felt so vulnerable. So seeing like, oh, wow, someone who I admire who has a exciting career and who is willing to be introspective and revealing in this way and expose the gap between public perception
从某种意义上说，当你写下那个东西时，不是说那是缺点，但我从你的脆弱中得到了安慰，因为你对那种脆弱的坦然接受而感到安慰，因为我也感到非常脆弱。所以看到，哦，哇，一个我钦佩的人展现出的脆弱，以及对这种脆弱的坦然接受，因为我感到非常脆弱。所以看到，哦，哇，一个我钦佩的人，有着激动人心的职业生涯，并且愿意以这种方式进行内省和自我剖析，暴露出公众看法与内心体验之间的差距，
and interior experience, that for me was really helpful. Sorry, that's such a long way to do that. I loved everywhere that. No, and I think it's your question too, which is like we were so in awe of Kathy Bates, but like maybe Kathy Bates just feels like the same tripping over her own feet actor that we all feel like when we first start a role
对我来说这真的很有帮助。抱歉，说这么长一段。我喜欢每一个地方。不，我认为这也是你的问题，也就是说我们对凯西·贝茨感到无比敬畏，但也许凯西·贝茨也觉得她和我们刚开始扮演一个角色时一样，是个会绊倒自己的普通演员，
or first start a job or whatever, but we never asked because we just assumed she must be filled with all this confidence and all of this, all of it. But that also goes back to you, Zach. You talk about all this anxiety and you're holding these things in Walmart and you can't believe you're on the show. You were seamlessly a part of our show from the very beginning. Like it's kind of blowing my mind that you're telling me that you were anxious or that you even were in experience
或者刚开始一份工作什么的，但我们从不问，因为我们只是假设她一定充满了自信和所有这些，这一切。但这也回到了你身上，扎克。你谈到了所有这些焦虑，你把这些事情憋在沃尔玛，你简直不敢相信自己能参演这部剧。从一开始，你就天衣无缝地成为了我们剧集的一部分。听到你说你曾经感到焦虑，甚至有过这种经历，简直让我大吃一惊，
because I knew you had done in the loop, but I assumed like there were all these other things too. I really had no idea that the office was your first television job. Like, and for how just amazing you were, right? So just amazing right out of the gate and such a smart improviser. I know I'm being improvneurred here, but I just love it when people are really smart and say really
因为我知道你演过《灵通意外》，但我以为还有所有这些其他事情。我真的不知道《办公室》是你的第一份电视剧工作。而且，你一上来就表现得如此惊艳，对吧？一登场就如此惊艳，而且是个如此聪明的即兴表演者。我知道我在这里进行即兴吹捧，但我就是喜欢那些非常聪明并且说出真正
what do you smart things and don't go for the obvious joke and don't go for too much and are understated and you're all of those things. And I have loved watching your scenes so much. And I love going to the script and reading the script and then watching your scenes. Cause you, I think maybe you and Steve improvise the most. Honestly, if you look at how many episodes you're in and improvise so well, you know? That's very sweet.
有什么聪明的话，不追求显而易见的笑话，不过分夸张，而且轻描淡写，你就是这样的人。我太喜欢看你的场景了。我喜欢去看剧本，阅读剧本，然后看你们的场景。因为你，我想也许你和史蒂夫是即兴发挥最多的。老实说，如果你看看你参演了多少集并且即兴发挥得那么好，你知道吗？太贴心了。
I mean, I, yeah, it's so nice. I start taking acting classes because I, I would hire in between, like, when we would be shooting, I would go back to New York and I had this acting coach named Anya Safer, who I would go shout out to Anya Safer. Because I'd never go into acting school or anything. So I would go through, like, scenes from Tennessee Williams plays and, like, take voice classes and do, like, Alexander technique and all this shit, because I was like, I just felt
我的意思是，我，是的，太好了。我开始上表演课，因为我，在拍摄间隙我会去面试，我会回纽约，我有一个表演教练叫安娅·塞弗，我会去向安娅·塞弗致敬。因为我从来没上过表演学校什么的。所以我会去排练田纳西·威廉姆斯戏剧中的场景，并且参加声音培训，做亚历山大技术之类的破事，因为我觉得，我只是觉得自己
I had such deep imposters in the drum because I hadn't done it before. So it's nice to hear that it wasn't flagrantly obvious. On set, that's good. This is a great segue for us to ask you if you had ever played Abe Lincoln other than on the office. I'd been sent an audition for Abe Lincoln Vampire Hunter where I had to learn the Gettysburg address
内心有如此深刻的冒名顶替感，因为我以前没做过。所以听到它不是那么显而易见，感觉挺好的。在片场，这很好。这对于我们问你是否除了在《办公室》里之外还演过亚伯拉罕·林肯来说，是一个很好的过渡。我曾被派去参加《吸血鬼猎人林肯》的试镜，我必须背诵葛底斯堡演说，
and I was not hired to be Abe Lincoln Vampire Hunter. But other than that, I'd never played Abelink in. Wait, so Abelink and recited the Gettysburg address while Gilly Abampires are being a vampire. I think he hunted the vampires. Oh, he hunted the vampires. But you know how it is of vampires. You start out hunting them and then you become one. Yeah. I think they just wanted to see people do the Getty's Brigadress to see if they were plausible as Lincoln and then they were going to like get to the vampire hunting in like a later stage of the casting process or something. So I did for a while know the Getty's Brigadress. Because you had done that prior to playing Abe Lincoln on the office.
但我没有被录用去演《吸血鬼猎人林肯》。但除此之外，我从未演过亚伯拉罕·林肯。等等，所以亚伯拉罕·林肯在吸血鬼袭击时背诵了葛底斯堡演说。我想他猎杀吸血鬼。哦，他猎杀吸血鬼。但你知道吸血鬼是怎么回事。你一开始猎杀他们，然后你自己也变成了一个。是的。我想他们只是想看看人们背诵葛底斯堡演说，看看他们作为林肯是否可信，然后他们会在选角过程的后期阶段加入猎杀吸血鬼的环节之类的事情。所以我有一段时间确实知道葛底斯堡演说。因为你在《办公室》里扮演亚伯拉罕·林肯之前做过那件事。
Yeah, I think so. Yeah. See, wow. Yeah. So there was a small part of you that had played Abe Lincoln on the office. I think so. Wow. So there was a small part of you that had played Abe Lincoln. It's not for an audition. I mean, like, my body had played Abe Lincoln my entire life. I had the doctor, I remember Abe Lincoln had something called Marfan Syndrome, which is like this. I guess it's like a congenital heart defect or something. I don't know.
对，我想是的。对。看，哇。是的，所以你身上有一小部分曾在《办公室》里扮演过亚伯拉罕·林肯。我想是的。哇。所以你身上有一小部分扮演过亚伯拉罕·林肯。不是为了试镜。我是说，我的身体一辈子都在扮演亚伯拉罕·林肯。我有那个医生，我记得亚伯拉罕·林肯有一种叫做马凡综合征的病，就像这个。我想这就像是一种先天性心脏缺陷什么的。我不知道。
Basically, like the symptoms are, your wings span is greater than your height. Then you have something called a Pectis Excavada, I think, which I have. It's your wings span is greater than your height, then you have something called a Pectis Xcavada, I think, which I have. It's like this weird divot in your chest. I remember going to the doctor and him being like, oh, Abe Lincoln had Marfan syndrome. We're gonna screen you for it. And then being just shocked that I didn't have it
基本上，就像症状是，你的臂展大于你的身高。然后你有一种叫做漏斗胸的东西，我想我有。你的臂展大于你的身高，然后你有一种叫做漏斗胸的东西，我想我有。就像你胸口有个奇怪的凹陷。我记得去看医生，他说，哦，亚伯拉罕·林肯有马凡综合征。我们要为你筛查一下。然后我非常震惊我竟然没有这个病，
because I had like all the... All the other. Yeah, I had like all the symptoms of Abe Lincoln's disease, but not the actual diagnosis, not to brag, hold your applause. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, what are some of your favorite scenes
因为我身上有所有的……所有的其他病症。是的，我身上有林肯疾病的所有症状，但没有实际的确诊，这不是吹牛，请收起掌声。是啊。是啊。哦，你最喜欢的一些场景是什么？
or moments from the show? It's funny, like, I remember hearing some interview with Mark Reiland, the actor where he said, like, when you die, probably like the thing that flashes before your eyes isn't the episodes of the shows, but the experience you had making them, like, and I think for me, when I think of the show, it's sort of a gauzy feeling of like,
或者剧中的精彩时刻？很有趣，我记得听过马克·里朗斯这位演员的采访，他说，当你死的时候，在你眼前闪过的可能不是剧集的剧集，而是你制作它们的经历，就像，我想对我来说，当我想到这部剧时，它是一种朦胧的感觉，就像，
I remember a lunch a lot. I remember like hanging out with people, like in between setups and stuff. In terms of scenes, I think it took me a while till after I was off the office when I started to be able to really enjoy scenes because I didn't feel like, oh god, what if I took this up, you know? Right, right. You could be an audience member and watch
我记住了很多午餐。我记得和大家一起出去玩，比如在布景之间等等。就场景而言，我想我离开《办公室》后过了一段时间才真正开始享受这些场景，因为我不觉得自己会想，天哪，如果我把这个搞砸了怎么办，对吧？对，对。你可以作为一个观众去观看
it. Yeah. And I really liked stuff where I like getting into fights with Ed Helms. I thought that was fun. I was like messing Ed Helms. I looked online to see what are the fan favorite quotes of Gabe. Oh, really? Yeah. and I share one of them with the internet. So I love so much in search committee when you just start asking him questions about the sun. And then Andy knows all this information about the sun and you say, shut up about the sun, shut up about the sun. So that made it as one of best Gabe quotes.
它。是的。我真的很喜欢我和埃德·赫尔姆斯起冲突的那些场景。我觉得那很有趣。我喜欢捉弄埃德·赫尔姆斯。我在网上查看了盖布最受粉丝欢迎的名言。哦，真的吗？是的。我与互联网分享其中之一。所以我在寻找委员会中非常喜欢你开始问他关于太阳的问题。然后安迪知道关于太阳的所有信息，你说，闭嘴关于太阳，闭嘴关于太阳。所以这成为了盖布的最佳名言之一。
It's also one of mine. Here's another one, walk away bitch. Oh, yeah, that was standy, right? Yeah, that's to and remember that. And then this is one I forgot. And I actually had to go and rewatch the episode. We haven't gotten to it yet, Jenna. It's from turf war. And Gabe says, sometimes I wonder if I have ovaries in my scrotum because I am great at girl talk.
这也是我的之一。这里还有另一个，滚开，婊子。哦，是的，那是对安迪说的，对吧？是的，那是对，还记得吗？然后这是我忘记的一个。我实际上不得不回去重新看那一集。我们还没看到那一集，珍娜。它来自地盘之争。盖布说，有时候我想知道我的阴囊里是否有卵巢，因为我很擅长女生之间的闲聊。
That's the most upsetting, sorry America. That's the most upsetting phrase I've ever heard. Oh my gosh. And the other one was there are plenty of people who love touching me. Oh, I remember that scene. It's heartbreaking. It's when Kelly hugs Gabe. It's hard break game. It's when Kelly hugs Gabe. It's hard break game.
那是令人最不安的，抱歉美国。那是我听过最令人不安的一句话。哦天哪。另一个是，有很多人喜欢触摸我。哦，我记得那一场戏。太令人心碎了。那是凯利拥抱盖布的时候。太心碎了，盖布。那是凯利拥抱盖布的时候。太心碎了，盖布。
It's when Kelly hugs Gabe. It's hard break game. It's when Kelly hugs Gabe. It's when Kelly hugs Gabe. It's when Kelly hugs Gabe. It's when Kelly hugs Gabe. It's when Kelly hugs Gabe. It's when Kelly hugs Gabe.
那是凯莉拥抱加布的时候。那是残酷的分手游戏。那是凯莉拥抱加布的时候。那是凯莉拥抱加布的时候。那是凯莉拥抱加布的时候。那是凯莉拥抱加布的时候。那是凯莉拥抱加布的时候。那是凯莉拥抱加布的时候。
It's when Kelly hugs Gabe. It's when Kelly hugs Gabe. It's when Kelly hugs Gabe. It's when Kelly hugs Gabe. It's when Kelly hugs Gabe. It's when Kelly hugs Gabe. It's when Kelly hugs Gabe. It's when Kelly hugs Gabe.
那是凯莉拥抱加布的时候。那是凯莉拥抱加布的时候。那是凯莉拥抱加布的时候。那是凯莉拥抱加布的时候。那是凯莉拥抱加布的时候。那是凯莉拥抱加布的时候。那是凯莉拥抱加布的时候。那是凯莉拥抱加布的时候。
It's when Kelly hugs Gabe. It's when Kelly hugs Gabe. It's when Kelly hugs Gabe. It's when Kelly hugs Gabe. are the search committee and you got to interview all of those amazing like actors doing the cameos. Are there any of that stood out to you? I remember Will our net would do this thing where he would sort of start improvising. Like he'd be joking around in this way that was so unbelievably funny in between takes. And then when they would call action was sort of like just continue in a way. I'm being like, oh, wow, that's fascinating. Like he's kind of in a, it doesn't stop in between cut and action.
那是凯莉拥抱加布的时候。那是凯莉拥抱加布的时候。那是凯莉拥抱加布的时候。那是凯莉拥抱加布的时候。你们是搜寻委员会，你们得面试所有那些客串的优秀演员。有没有哪个让你印象深刻？我记得威尔·阿奈特会做这样一件事，他会开始即兴发挥。就像他在镜头之间开玩笑，那种好笑简直难以置信。然后当他们喊“开始”时，就好像是某种延续。我就觉得，哦，哇，这太迷人了。就像他在一种……在“停”和“开始”之间它并没有停止。
He's like kind of not in a tiring way. You know, there's people who are like on in a way that, it wasn't like that. It was just like, he was sort of in this, it was like he was keeping it like a simmering or something. I remember being fascinated by that. Yeah. And I remember feeling like immediately like Ray Romano,
就好像……并不是那种让人觉得累的方式。你知道，有些人那种“时刻在线”的状态，但不是那样的。就好像他处于一种……就像他在让情绪一直处于微沸状态什么的。我记得当时对此着迷。对。而且我记得立刻就有一种感觉，比如雷·罗马诺，
I just went to like rest my head on his shoulder I think he's like so warm and And and I really loved him and Then I also like it was fun. I remember we like interview people from the office. Yeah, just fun to do like Your interview of Mindy as Kelly was really funny and I think it's in the bloopers because Gabe decides that oh, maybe I'm going to be the voice of reason here and he looks at Jim and Toby when Kelly walks in and goes, we don't really need to go through all this, do we? If we're not, we're not, this isn't like a serious interview,
我当时就想把头靠在他的肩膀上，我觉得他太温暖了，而且……而且我真的很喜欢他。然后我也觉得……挺有意思的。我记得我们好像面试了办公室里的人。对，做那种采访真的很有趣。你以凯莉的身份采访明迪真的超级搞笑，我想那段花絮应该被收录进去了，因为加布觉得，哦，也许我要在这里扮演理性的声音，当凯莉走进来时，他看着吉姆和托比说，我们其实没必要经历这一切，对吧？如果不合适就算了，这又不是什么严肃的面试，
right? And they both just throw you under the bus and Toby's like, no, I think we, it is serious. And then Gabe says to Kelly, what are your weaknesses? And Kelly goes, I don't have any ass. This is something like that. But you guys, you could tell that Mindy was like breaking, and just the whole scene is so funny. I imagine there's a lot of great bloopers from that day. Yeah, I mean, and by that point, I guess that was late enough in the shooting process
对吧？然后他们两个直接把你推出去当替罪羊，托比说，不，我觉得我们……这确实很严肃。然后加布对凯莉说，你有什么缺点？凯莉说，我没有任何屁股。大概是类似这样的话。但你们……你们能看出明迪当时快要笑场了，整个场景真的太逗了。我猜那天有很多精彩的NG镜头。对，我的意思是，到那个时候，我猜拍摄进度已经够晚了，
where I felt like my blood pressure had dropped incrementally a little bit and I was able to. It looked like you were having fun. I remember enjoying those scenes more where I was like, okay, I think after they brought me back for another season, I thought, well, if they were horrified, they wouldn't have done that. And that really put me at ease where I just thought, okay, well, if they've decided they want me here, then it's their funeral.
我觉得我的血压逐渐降下来了一点，我能够……看起来你玩得很开心。我记得更享受那些场景，当时我就想，好吧，我想在他们让我回归拍下一季之后，我觉得，如果他们觉得震惊，他们就不会这么做了。这真的让我感到安心，我就想，好吧，既然他们决定让我留在这里，那这就是他们自找的。
I can't, you know, I'll take it. The other thing when I looked up the character Gabe and I did like an image search, one of the first things that comes up is Gabe as Lady Gaga. Yeah. That costume was, oh my gosh, I just remember you were in here and make up for so long. Yeah. You had the eyelashes. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
我没法……你知道的，我认了。还有一件事，当我搜索加布这个角色并进行图片搜索时，最先跳出来的结果之一就是变装成Lady Gaga的加布。对。那套服装，哦天哪，我只记得你弄妆发在里面待了超级久。对。你有假睫毛。对，对，对。
Yeah. I never felt more like myself on set. I think, you know, I never walked in high heels before. I don't know where they found high heels my size, but it was- It was shoe size. 11 and a half, a modest 11 and a half. We're not, you know. But it was, I don't know if you guys know this.
对。我在片场从来没有像那时那样觉得自己真正做自己。我想，你知道的，我以前从来没穿过高跟鞋。我不知道他们在哪找到我这个尺码的高跟鞋，但那是——鞋码。11码半，一个刚刚好的11码半。我们不是那种……你知道的。但这……我不知道你们知不知道这个。
Extremely hard to walk in. Yeah. We have an idea. Why? Yeah, yeah. I know. No man has ever told you this. It was so hard to move.
穿起来极其难走。对。我们大概能想象。为什么？对，对。我知道。从来没有哪个男人跟你说过这事。移动起来太难了。
I couldn't believe it. I was like, wait, people do this for hours at a time? It's kind of insane. It's ridiculous when you think about it. It's like, I'm the design issue where you're up on your tippy toes. Now, go walk all day. Not just that.
我简直不敢相信。我当时就想，等等，人们竟然能连续几个小时做这事？这简直太疯狂了。你想想这有多荒谬。这就像是个设计问题，你得一直踮着脚尖。然后去走上一整天。不仅如此。
So many high heels. They're made for a foot where you're up on your tippy toes. Now go walk all day. Not just that, so many high heels, they're made for a foot where you just have one long center toe. Yes, true. Not even the shape of your foot. Which is likely I do have that design. That is. I just have a long center toe. That was also an Abraham Lincoln.
很多高跟鞋。它们的设计就是为了让你的脚一直踮着脚尖。现在去走上一整天，不仅如此，很多高跟鞋的设计，都是针对那种只有一根长长的中间脚趾的脚。是的，没错。甚至都不是你脚的形状。巧的是我确实有这种设计。确实。我只有一根长长的中间脚趾。亚伯拉罕·林肯也是这样的。
Yes, that's one of the symptoms of my advanced syndrome. Just a single long toe. In terms of volume, it's the same volume as five toes, but just in one in the one toe. Yes, exactly. All right, we have one other question we've been curious about. Great.
是的，那是我高级综合症的症状之一。只有一根单独的长脚趾。就体积而言，它和五根脚趾的体积一样，只不过全部集中在这一根脚趾里。对，完全正确。好了，我们还有一个一直很好奇的问题。太棒了。
The great Danes. You had to work a lot with these giant dogs. Was there anything like any memory from working with those dogs? Yeah, they were like frustratingly professional. Really? Yeah, I was like, you know, with your dog, you just want to like rub your face in there,
大丹犬。你必须和这些巨大的狗狗有很多对手戏。跟这些狗狗合作有什么记忆深刻的事情吗？对，它们专业到让人沮丧。真的吗？对，我就觉得，你知道，对你自己的狗，你只想把脸埋进它们的，
snout, you just want to be like, oh, I love you, you're beautiful, you're a miracle. And they were just like, we're working. They just were so focused, they had that like working dog thing where they were just like not screwing around. Yeah. No snuggles, no snuggles. I was like spoon me, great.
口鼻里，你只想说，哦，我爱你，你太漂亮了，你是个奇迹。而它们的态度却是：我们在工作。它们太专注了，身上有那种工作犬的特质，就是那种绝不胡闹的架势。对。没有拥抱，没有拥抱。我当时就想，快来抱抱我，大宝贝。
And they're like, no, thank you. No was like spoon me, great. And they're like, no thank you. No thank you, strange human. I'm working. Yeah, I was like, it truly was like, you ever meet like one of those former child stars who's been like working from the time they were three and they were like, where's my light? Okay, I just need a little bit of eyebrow pencil
而它们的反应是：不用了，谢谢。不用了，奇怪的人。我在工作。对，我当时就觉得，这真的就像……你有没有见过那种从三岁就开始工作的昔日童星，他们会问：我的灯光在哪？好吧，我只需要一点眉笔，
and let's go. You know, those people who are just like, they were like that, but just the canine version. Yeah. Do you share Gabe's love of horror films? No. I mean, I like some horror movies, but not really. What I do love is I really like wake up pranks.
然后我们就可以开始了。你知道那些人就是这样，它们就是犬类版本。对。你和加布一样喜欢恐怖电影吗？没有。我的意思是，我喜欢一些恐怖电影，但其实不多。我真正喜欢的是，我特别喜欢恶作剧叫醒别人。
Do you guys know about wake up pranks? No. Do you wake up someone in a horrible manner? Yeah, it's like people waking up their friends in mean ways. Oh, no. And people get scared. And I think it's very funny and very mean. And there's one where they're like,
你们知道恶作剧叫醒别人吗？不知道。就是用很可怕的方式叫醒某人？对，就是那种以恶劣的方式叫醒朋友。哦，不。然后人们会被吓到。我觉得这非常搞笑，也很恶劣。有一个恶作剧是这样的，
disguised asleep. I guess they got like fast food. They're in a van disguised asleep. He's got like a burger on his lap, but he fell asleep before he ate his burger. And I think there's like a truck with one of those, it's like one of those trucks that pulls cars behind it. So it looks like the car is facing.
假装睡着。我猜他们是买了快餐。他们在一辆面包车里假装睡着。他的大腿上放着一个汉堡，但在吃汉堡之前睡着了。然后我记得有一辆卡车，那种拖着汽车的拖车。所以看起来那辆车正对着……
Oh, yeah, like the vehicle. Uh-huh. You can mistake it as an oncoming vehicle. Right, right. So this guy's asleep. So everyone in the car decides to wake up, prank him. And what they do is they swerve and scream all at the same time, and he wakes up
哦，对，就像那种交通工具。嗯哼。你会把它误认为是迎面开来的车。对，对。所以这家伙睡着了。车里的所有人决定搞个恶作剧叫醒他。他们做的是同时急转弯和尖叫，他醒了过来，
and he sees this car in front of him. And he thinks, you know, this is it. And he screams and he just squeezes the hell out of his burger. He just squeezes this burger so hard. And then I show him slow mo of just like face contouring and I'm squeezing the burger. It's so fun.
看到前面有辆车。他以为，你知道，这下完了。他大叫一声，然后死死地捏住他的汉堡。他把那个汉堡捏得超级紧。然后我给他看慢镜头，就是面部扭曲变形，同时在捏汉堡。太好玩了。
It's very mean and I don't think it's right, but it is very funny. And then I also like close call videos where it's like, I can't stand like fail videos where people get hurt. I can't stand it. But close call videos. Oh, and someone almost falls? Yes. Yes. That I. It's the best.
这真的很恶劣，我也觉得不太对劲，但确实超级搞笑。然后我还喜欢惊险逃生视频，就是那种……我受不了那种人们受伤的出丑视频。我简直受不了。但是惊险逃生视频。哦，就是有人差点摔倒？对。对。那个我……太棒了。
It's the best. Like I haven't seen the videos, but I will tell you, I have a memory I will never forget. I was in the Dallas, Fort Worth airport. And there was this long corridor that we were all walking down, right? And there's a woman coming kind of swimming up stream against all of us. She's got no soul. She was clearly very late for her flight. Okay. And she is running. I'm talking a full sprint with like trying to juggle a carry on, but a full sprint.
太棒了。就像我没看过那些视频，但我有个永远不会忘记的记忆。我在达拉斯-沃斯堡机场。有一条很长的走廊，我们都在往前走，对吧？然后有一个女人迎面朝我们逆流而行。她简直毫无灵魂。她显然赶不上航班了。好吧。她在奔跑。我说的是全速冲刺，还试图兼顾随身行李的那种全速冲刺。
And she's in wedge flip flops. And she is running. And we can see her from so far in this corridor and she's running and the front of her flip flop bends forward under her foot and then she lurches forward and then she tries to overcompensate and she lurches back and she did it for probably it felt like 10 minutes. It was like wait, wait, wait, wait, and we were all all so invested. It was like, I don't know, 80 strangers. And we're like, is she going down?
她脚上穿着坡跟人字拖。而且她在奔跑。我们从走廊很远的地方就能看到她在跑，然后她那只人字拖的前端在她的脚底下向前翻折，接着她身体向前倾，然后她试图过度矫正，又向后倾斜，她这样持续了大概……感觉有10分钟。就像是，等，等，等，等，我们所有人都高度投入。大概有，我不知道，80个陌生人。我们都在想：她要摔倒了吗？
What do we do? And then she, right before she faced planted, she pulled herself up. Yeah. And we were all like, and then she ran past us. I'll never forget it. Oh my God.
我们该怎么办？然后她，就在脸着地的前一秒，把自己给撑住了。对。然后我们所有人都发出“哇”的感叹，接着她从我们身边跑了过去。我永远不会忘记那一幕。哦，天哪。
I've seen videos, if you saw the videos of someone who's like slipping on ice, but for like a very long time. It's like that. It's like that. It's like that. It's like that. It's like that. It's like that.
我看过一些视频，如果你看过那种在冰上滑倒的视频，但是持续了很长一段时间。就像那样。就像那样。就像那样。就像那样。就像那样。就像那样。
It's like that. It's like that. It's like that. It's like that. It's like that. It's like that. It's like that. It's like that. It's like that. It's like that. It's like that. that seems to never stop. And when it turns out good, right? So relieved. And it put there's so many,
就像那样。就像那样。就像那样。就像那样。就像那样。就像那样。就像那样。就像那样。就像那样。就像那样。就像那样。好像永远都不会停下来。而当结果变好的时候，对吧？如释重负。而且这里面有好多，
and you can watch them to compilation. It's like people like their kid almost, like is riding a bike and almost runs into something and they swoop in and grab them or it's like, it's just like humans evading disaster is like the best. Have you seen the videos of people who they're scaring someone? Yes. But they're doing it by pretending
你可以看它们的合集。就像人们的孩子差点……在骑自行车时差点撞到什么东西，然后他们冲过去一把抓住，或者是……就像人类躲过灾难简直是太棒了。你们看过那种吓唬别人的视频吗？看过。但他们的做法是假装
that they're scared of something themselves. Yes, and then the other person runs away. Yes, they're moral again. So like there's like a woman and she's like taking out the trash with her husband and she opens up the trash cannon that she's like, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah He has to be like anything. And it's just like the firefly respond. But the psychology behind it, it's so interesting because it's like, I share fear with you. Yeah.
他们自己被什么东西吓到了。对，然后另一个人逃跑了。对，他们又回到了道德制高点。比如有一个女人和她丈夫一起去倒垃圾，她打开垃圾桶盖然后说“啊、啊、啊、啊、啊、啊、啊、啊”，丈夫也跟着“啊、啊、啊、啊、啊、啊、啊、啊”，结果他们俩都开始尖叫。他根本不知道为什么要叫。这就好像是萤火虫的应激反应。但背后的心理学太有趣了，因为这就像是：我和你分享恐惧。对。
We share that. But the one person, it's just pretending. And that's the other person. I know it's really fascinating. I kind of want to try it out. You should try it. It's a cheap prank. You have to do is excite. There's one more I have to say because these are really fascinating. I kind of want to try it out. You should try it. It's a cheap prank. Y'all you have to do is excite. There's one more I have to say
我们感同身受。但其中一个人其实是在假装。而另一个人……我知道这真的太迷人了。我有点想亲自试试。你应该试试。这是一种低成本的恶作剧。你只需要兴奋起来。我还有最后一个要说，因为这些真的太迷人了。我有点想亲自试试。你应该试试。这是一种低成本的恶作剧。你只需要兴奋起来。我还有最后一个要说，
because these are now fascinating. You might like it. So there's the other one where you're in a group, like your family, and you pick someone and you say, like I learned, we're gonna do a magic trick and make you visible. And you put a sheet over them
因为这些现在太迷人了。你可能会喜欢。所以还有另一个恶作剧是这样的：你在一个群体里，比如你的家庭，你挑中一个人，然后对他们说，就像我了解到的，我们要变个魔术让你隐形。你把一条床单盖在他们身上，
and then you say some magic words and then you pull the sheet off and everyone in the room has agreed to pretend that the person is invisible. Oh, that's amazing. It's always the mom. They always do it to the mom, right? And then so then they pull the sheet off
然后念几句咒语，接着把床单猛地掀开，房间里的所有人都串通过，要假装这个人已经隐形了。哦，太绝了。通常都是对妈妈下手。他们总是对妈妈这么做，对吧？然后他们掀开床单，
and then everyone's like, no way! Holy, oh my God. And then the person's like, what, oh my God, what, what, what, you can't, I don't get it. That's amazing. Also the fact that it's the mom, like,
接着每个人都说：不会吧！天哪，我的天！然后那个人就会说：什么，天哪，什么，什么，什么，你们怎么能这样，我搞不懂。这太绝了。而且对象居然是妈妈，
like an invisible mom, I feel like so many moms in family dynamics are just the invisible caretaker. They're all ready. They're all ready. It's like that's like an invisible labor. That SNL sketch at Christmas, everyone's saying, I got a piano and the mom goes, and I got a robe. And that's all she got. And it's like over and over. But then I got a car. I got a piano and the mom goes, and I got a robe. And that's all she got.
就像是一个隐形的妈妈，我觉得在家庭动态中，很多妈妈都只是隐形的照顾者。她们早就准备好了。她们早就准备好了。这就像是一种隐形劳动。圣诞节的那部SNL小品里，每个人都说：我得到了一架钢琴。而妈妈说：我得到了一件长袍。那是她得到的全部。而且是一次又一次。然后我说我得到了一辆车。我得到了一架钢琴，而妈妈说：我得到了一件长袍。那是她得到的全部。
And it's like over and over. But then I got a car. I got a robe. Also, at the end, they're like, wait a second. What's this secret pile of presents? And the mom's like, oh, and they're like, it's presents for the dog. And then the dog gets a robe as well.
而且是一次又一次。然后我说我得到了一辆车。我得到了一件长袍。还有，在最后，他们说：等一下。这个秘密的礼物堆是什么？妈妈说：哦。然后他们说：这是给狗的礼物。接着那只狗也得到了一件长袍。
I think I'm gonna watch the one of, particularly the one where they're scared. Where they act scared. Yes, it's very fun. It's, I cannot wait. It's so interesting. It's so interesting that people like share fear. It's fascinating.
我想我会去看那个系列的视频，特别是他们被吓到的那集。他们表现得很害怕的那集。对，太好玩了。我、我简直迫不及待。这太有趣了。人们会分享恐惧，这真的太迷人了。
I heard that, I don't even know if this is true. This could just be something like I am basically making up. But that like laughter, like the origins of laughter, is it was like a way that like monkeys could tell each other that a perceived danger was no longer a threat. Like so basically it's like, okay, we're a bunch of monkeys. Like we think we see a tiger, everyone gets tense. And then I realized it was not a tiger,
我听说过——我甚至不知道这是否是真的。这可能只是我基本上瞎编出来的东西——但笑声的起源，就像是猴子之间用来告诉彼此某个察觉到的危险已经不再是威胁的一种方式。所以基本上就是：好吧，我们是一群猴子。我们觉得看到了一只老虎，每个人都变得紧张。然后我意识到那不是老虎，
it's something that looked like a tiger, but it's an tiger. Then we all laugh and it's a way of quickly dispersing the information that like what seemed to be threatening is in fact not a threat. So it's like this rolling sound that like lets everyone know. It's like a fire-john reverse. It makes so much sense. Right. And then also it makes so much sense. Why comedy is something we're drawn to watch and that like su there's us. It's a real, you know. Oh, that's interesting. Yes. Yes, I mean, I remember when I injured my back, when I broke my back and I watched the Larry Sanders show.
它只是长得像老虎的东西，但它不是老虎。然后我们都笑了，这是一种快速传播信息的方式，表明看似具有威胁性的东西实际上并不是威胁。所以这就像是一个滚动的声音，让每个人都知道。这就像是一个反向的消防警报。这太合理了。对。而且这也完全合理解释了
Me and Creed and Jenna one night in her hotel room binged the Larry Sanders show. And that laughter, it brings you relief, right? And maybe it goes all the way back to that. Just bunch of monkeys. Releasing some porn, they're no tiger. Yeah. Yeah. That's our whole show is just, I'm very scared of what Michael Scott is going to say or do right now. Okay. All right. All right.
为什么喜剧是我们会被吸引去观看的东西，而且它对我们……这确实是一个……哦，太有趣了。是的。是的，我的意思是，我记得当我背部受伤时，当我摔断背脊的时候，我看了《拉里·桑德斯秀》。我和克里德还有珍娜有一天晚上在她酒店的房间里刷完了《拉里·桑德斯秀》。那种笑声能给你带来解脱，对吧？也许这一切都可以追溯到那个源头。只是一群猴子。释放一些压力，根本没有老虎。对。对。我们的整个节目就是：我很害怕迈克尔·斯科特现在会说出什么或做出什么。好吧。好吧。好吧。
I think that's right. It's like tension, cringe, release. Yeah. You know, set up tension, punchline. Like, yeah, I don't know. Again, I could, that could be total malarkey, but I mean, it tracks, I've been really into, there's a show about animals on Netflix and we watch the one about dogs. It's so good. Yeah, and dogs do this little sniffy snorty thing when they're, you know, how they play fight
我觉得确实如此。就像是紧张、尴尬、释放。对。你知道的，制造紧张，抖包袱。就像，对，我不知道。再说一次，这可能完全是胡说八道，但我的意思是，这说得通。我最近迷上了Netflix上的一部关于动物的节目，我们看了狗的那集。太棒了。对，狗狗在进行那种假装打架的时候会发出一种哼哧哼哧的声音，
and it's to let the other dog know that I'm not serious. So if you hear your dog and now my little two to-wawa rescues when they play, I hear it, they go, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, sh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, sh, sh, shh, sh, sh, sh, sh, sh, sh, sh, shh, sh, shh, shh, sh, sh, sh, sh, sh, sh, sh, sh, sh, sh, sh, sh, sh, sh, sh, sh, sh, sh, sh, sh, sh, seriously when you're trying to like, I mean it. I really mean it guys. Like now you don't. Now you know you're being silly. Do you get recognized as Gabe? Sometimes, yeah. And what is that like?
那是为了让另一只狗知道我不是认真的。所以如果你听到你的狗发出这种声音——现在我的两只小型吉娃娃救援犬在玩耍时，我能听到它们发出这种声音：呼，呼，呼，呼，呼，呼，呼……它们是认真的，当你想表达……我是认真的。我真的是认真的，伙计们。现在你们不用了。现在你知道你们是在胡闹了。你会被认出是加布吗？有时会，对。那是什么感觉？
I had a really bad one recently, so I'm making the show now this like stop-motion show. And in it, there's a like a lactation station, you know, that they have the airport. And we were getting designs for them. And I was like, oh, I want something really simple. And I was in an airport. There was an empty lactation station.
我最近遇到过一次非常糟糕的经历，我当时正在制作一档定格动画节目。在节目里，有一个……你知道机场里有的那种哺乳室。我们在获取它们的设计方案。然后我就想：哦，我想要一些非常简单的东西。当时我在机场。那里正好有一个空着的哺乳室。
And I wanted to send a picture to the production designer to be like, this is what we're going for. This is a perfect example, right? So I started to take a picture of the lactation station as someone came up to me and was like, hey man, you were Gabe on the office. There's not lost to me. The Gabe is a, in many ways, quite a creepy guy. Yeah. And so this guy just saw me by myself in an airport photographing a lactation station. Oh, no. Like a true predator from hell. I mean, like that's an insane thing to do, right? To take a picture. Like, he has no context.
我想给布景设计师发张照片，告诉他：这就是我们想要的风格。这是一个完美的例子，对吧？于是我开始给那个哺乳室拍照，这时有个人朝我走过来，对我说：嘿，兄弟，你是在《办公室》里演加布的那个人吧。我没有忘记这一点。加布在很多方面都是一个相当令人毛骨悚然的家伙。对。于是这家伙刚好看到我一个人在机场里拍哺乳室的照片。哦，不。就像一个来自地狱的真正变态。我的意思是，这真的是一件疯狂的事情，对吧？拍照。而且他没有任何上下文。
And if I say, this is for a show, that sounds even worse. It's like, it's for a show, really, buddy. Like, and so it was, that was a truly mortifying where I'm like, I, he must think I'm like, the Gabe is like a tone down version of me, based on I'm based on that experience. But yeah, people, people sometimes will recognize me from the show.
如果我说这是为了一个节目，听起来甚至更糟糕。就像是：这是为了一个节目，真的吗，老兄？所以，那真是一次极其丢脸的经历，我在想，他一定觉得加布只是我本色出演的一个稍微收敛的版本，根据我的那个经历来看。不过，对，人们有时会在节目之外认出我来。
So after the office, you did Silicon Valley, you've done all these other things. Do you still get approached more for being on the office or for other roles, or is it pretty 50-50? I'd say it's probably 50-50 with the office and then everything else I've ever done. So it's like the single thing, maybe more. Well, I don know. Look at belly. Yeah, it's probably around 50-50. It depends. It's like demographically specific. Yeah. You know. And it's interesting. If it's younger people,
所以在《办公室》之后，你演了《硅谷》，你还演了所有这些其他的作品。人们找你更多是因为你在《办公室》里的角色，还是因为其他角色，或者基本上是一半对一半？我猜大概是《办公室》占一半，然后我演过的所有其他作品占另一半。所以这是单一作品里最多的，也许更多。不过，我不知道。你看贝利。对，大概是五五开吧。这取决于具体情况。这跟人口统计学有关。对。你知道的。而且很有趣。如果是年轻人，
it's probably the office. If it's really young people, I think it's so sweet to me that kids find it so comforting. It's a kind of emotional wall paper. People have watched it a million times, they'll turn it on as a way of feeling like they're kind of among their friends or in a kind of soothing, warm, silly environment. I think it's so sweet. And so it's nice when it's like some whatever 19-year-old who's immersed in the scrant and paper industry fictional world, I think that's so sweet. I like that. Have you rewatched the show?
那大概是因为《办公室》。如果是非常年轻的人，我真的觉得很暖心，孩子们觉得这部剧能带来极大的安慰。它就像是一种情感壁纸。人们已经看过无数遍了，他们会把它当作一种背景播放，以此来寻找一种仿佛置身于朋友之间、或者处于一种舒缓、温暖、愚蠢环境中的感觉。我觉得这太贴心了。所以当某个19岁的年轻人沉浸在斯克兰顿纸业公司的虚构世界里时，这真的很美好。我喜欢这样。你重温过这部剧吗？
Some of it. I hate watching anything I'm in, so not that stuff. But I'd already watched the show so much when I came out. I think I would rewatch the show a lot before I was on the show, but I haven't done the wall-to-wall rewatch. We hadn't either. This is the first time for us. I'd seen episodes here and there.
看过一部分。我讨厌看任何自己出演的东西，所以不是我出场的那部分。不过在它播出来之前我已经看过很多遍了。我想我在参演这部剧之前会经常重温它，但我并没有从头到尾重温过。我们也没有。这是我们的第一次。我零零散散地看集数。
We've talked about that. This is really our first time to see some of these episodes in a long time since they aired. Does it feel like, does watching the show feel like you're looking at a photo album of your friends and your life in a way, or does it feel like you can suspend disbelief and get lost in the story of the show? Like, are you able to invest in the fictional reality
我们聊过这个。这是我们这么长时间以来——自从它们播出之后——第一次真正重新观看其中一些剧集。看这部剧的感觉，是不是就像在翻看你朋友们和你的生活的相片册，还是说你能暂停不信感，迷失在节目的故事中？就像，你在观看时能够投入到节目的虚构现实中吗？
of the show when you're watching it? invest in the fictional reality of the show when you're watching it? I think so. Because of the passage of time, it's both things. I have a lot of nostalgic thoughts and feelings. I get really sentimental when I'm watching it. I remember parts of my life that were happening when we were making those episodes. I miss people when I watch it. But I can also when I watch it, what's weird is I have images of all the things you can't see in the episode. So like I can feel Brian Whittle holding his boom above my desk in a scene when I'm watching the rewatch.
你在观看时能够投入到节目的虚构现实中吗？我想是的。因为时间的流逝，这两种感觉都有。我有很多怀旧的想法和感受。在观看时我会变得非常多愁善感。我想起我们在拍摄那些剧集时生活中正在发生的部分。看的时候我会想念那些人。但同时当我观看时，奇怪的是，我对那些你在剧集中看不到的东西都有画面感。比如当我在重温时，我能感觉到布赖恩·惠特尔在某个场景中把他的挑杆话筒举在我的办公桌上方。
You know, I can like feel where, oh, I thought video village was over in the conference room for this one and Kelly's shouting out some safety meeting. So it's like all of the behind the camera stuff pops into my head as well. But then at the same time, I have found myself getting invested in the characters. Like I personally feel that Aaron is not the one for Andy. And I am getting angry. It's being shoved down my throat.
你知道的，我能感觉到……哦，我以为当时的视频监视村在这个场景的会议室那边，而凯莉正在大喊大叫某个安全会议。所以所有摄像机背后的东西也会涌入我的脑海。但与此同时，我发现自己也开始对角色投入感情。比如我个人觉得艾瑞安不适合安迪。我真的开始生气了。这简直是硬塞给我们的剧情。
That I'm being told that they're the perfect couple. When I actually feel like Andy is thriving with his current girlfriend, Jessica. Jessica. Yeah. It is great. I like Jessica. Yeah.
他们告诉我他们是天生一对。而我实际上觉得安迪和现任女友杰西卡在一起过得很好。杰西卡。是的。真的很棒。我喜欢杰西卡。对。
You know? So I don't know. So I do, I have like some fan reactions when I watch. That's interesting. Show as well. Yeah. What about you, Ange. Oh, I mean, I think you said that so well.
你知道吗？所以我不知道。所以，当我观看时，我确实会有一些粉丝的反应。这很有趣。节目也是如此。是的。你呢，安吉。哦，我是说，你这话说的太好了。
That's exactly how I feel. It's both for me. It's a photo album and I'm in the audience and I kind of switch back and forth. I have really strong memories of episodes, you know, when things were happening in my life. And I watch it with that layer. Wow. So it's not even just the environment of the set, but it's the environment of your life at that time.
我的感受完全一样。对我和来说，这既是一本相册，我又是观众，我会在这两种身份之间来回切换。我对剧集有着非常深刻的记忆，你知道的，当我的生活中发生某些事情的时候。我带着那种情绪层叠去观看。哇。所以这不仅是片场的环境，更是你当时的生活环境。
Yeah. That's fascinating. It was what, nine years of our life, and, you know, babies were born and family members passed away. And it's a lot of life happens in nine years. And I just watched that play out through this other filter of being a character. It's kind of, it's really surreal. That's trippy. Yeah, a friend of mine said to me, I was like talking about some,
是的。太迷人了。那是我们九年的生活，而且，你知道的，孩子们出生了，家庭成员离世了。九年里发生了太多的生活。我只是看着这一切在扮演角色的另一层过滤下上演。这有点，真的非常超现实。太魔幻了。是的，我的一个朋友对我说，我当时在谈论某个，
maybe New York or something, she goes, well, places aren't places as much as their times. Like when you think of a place often, you're thinking of a time. And so it's not necessarily the geography of the place, but it's the sort of psychic place you were in in your life, right? Like where what was happening or who you were at that time? It's so interesting that it's the show where you're being somebody different Like you're playing a different person, but also you were a different person in your life at that time, right?
也许是纽约或者什么地方，她说，比起地方本身，地方更是时代的代名词。就像当你想到一个地方时，你往往是在想一个时代。所以不一定是那个地方的地理位置，而是你当时人生中所处的某种心理位置，对吧？就像当时发生了什么，或者你是谁？很有趣的是，在这个节目里你成了另一个人，就像你在扮演一个不同的人，但同时你在当时的生活中也是一个不同的人，对吧？
Like the circumstances of your life were different your relationships were different everything was different Can I just like one work? I'm just curious. Yes, yes, yes. For you guys, if there's something like you guys could go back and tell yourselves, like in that hour town style, like what would you, like if you could go back to like season one and visit with you, like as your own like fairy godmother or ghost of Christmas future or whatever, like what would you say, or maybe that's too hard a question. Hmm. I would say I think there are a lot of ways that I know how to advocate for myself professionally
就像你生活的环境不同了，你的关系不同了，一切都不同了。我能插一句吗？我只是好奇。可以，可以，可以。对你们来说，如果有什么事是你们可以回到过去告诉自己的，就像那种《奇幻小镇》的风格，你们会……如果你们可以回到第一季，以仙女教母或未来圣诞幽灵之类的身份去探望当时的自己，你会说些什么，或者也许这个问题太难了。嗯。我会说，我觉得有很多方法让我现在懂得如何在职场上为自己争取权益，
now that I had to really learn on the go. And I feel like in some cases, I even got some bad advice. There were ways where as you're kind of an up and coming actor and maybe you're suddenly on this hit show, there are a lot of people that have ideas for you professionally. And I was just happy being on the office. I didn't need an and. I didn't need to also have a product line or also be a movie star. And yet I felt the energy coming at me, telling me I needed
而这些我都是在摸索中真正学会的。我觉得在某些情况下，我甚至得到了一些糟糕的建议。在某种程度上，当你是一个崭露头角的演员，或者可能突然参演了这档热门节目时，会有很多人对你的职业生涯指手画脚。而我当时只要能参演《办公室》就很开心了。我不需要“而且”。我不需要同时拥有一个产品线，也不需要同时成为电影明星。然而我感受到了扑面而来的压力，告诉我我需要
to do all this more. And I think in some ways, you know, I would do the TV show and then I would spend my hiatus doing all the more that everyone was telling me that I wanted and that I had to do and that this is what you do next. And the truth is, is I just wanted to spend my hiatus traveling and enjoying my life and being in love. And sometimes I look back on that time and I think,
做所有这些更多的事情。我想在某些方面，你知道的，我会拍电视剧，然后我会把拍摄间隙的时间都用来做那些每个人都告诉我我想要、我必须去做、以及接下来就该做的事情。但事实是，我只是想把拍摄间隙的时间用来旅行、享受生活和谈恋爱。有时我回想起那段时光，我会想，
wow, I was just too busy doing a bunch of things that I felt like were expected of me. But my truth was, I just want to be on this TV show. I love it. I'm happy. This is enough. And it took me a really long time to get to a place where I didn't let other people's idea of what my life should be.
哇，我当时只是太忙于做一堆我觉得别人对我的期望的事情。但我的真实想法是，我只想参演这部电视剧。我热爱它。我很开心。这就足够了。我花了很长时间才走到这样一个地步：不再让别人对我的生活应该是什么样的看法来左右我。
Like I figured out what my ambition is in life, but I spent a lot of years. I don't know. I mean, I don't necessarily regret any of those movies or any of those experiences or any of those things, but I think it's a life lesson coming to a place where you're like, well, what's enough for me is okay. Yes, that's right. One or need things other people need. What I need is enough and that's okay. Yeah. And I think it's even still shocking to people need is enough and that's okay. Yeah. And I think it's even still shocking to people when I say, no, the podcast is enough. I enjoy this. I like concentrating on it.
就像我弄清了我在生活中的雄心是什么，但我花了很多年。我不知道。我是说，我并不一定后悔拍过的那些电影、经历过的那些事情或其中的任何一部分，但我觉得这是一个生活教训，让你达到这样一种状态：你会觉得，对我来说足够了这就挺好。是的，没错。不需要别人需要的东西。我需要的就足够了，这就挺好。是的。而且我觉得当我说“不，这个播客就足够了，我很享受这个，我喜欢专注于它”时，大家依然会感到震惊。
I like this being my one thing. I think maybe that's me. Maybe I'm in like a monogamous worker like I have a job I like to do. And that's the job I like to do. And fully and I enjoy it. And then I like to put it away. Like, I don't need a lot of ants. I don't, so. That's a great. I wish I could have told myself to trust that more in me. It's so noisy, probably, when you write like,
我喜欢把它当作我唯一的事。也许那就是我吧。也许我就像一个专一的打工人，我有我喜欢做的工作。那就是我喜欢做的工作。而且全身心地享受它。然后我喜欢把它放下。就像，我不需要很多“而且”。我不需要，所以。这太棒了。我希望我能告诉自己要更多地信任内心的这一点。当你创作时，周围的声音可能太嘈杂了，
and if all of a sudden you're on the show and it's a success, and it's the cacophony of that, and all of the projection that it cooks up and everything. I think that yeah. There's a lot of like fear based sort of communication in that too, which is like, well, listen, if you don't do this now, it's not going to be there later. No one's going to want you later if you don't do this now, or you won't work later if you're not working now or any of it, you know.
如果你突然参演了这个节目而且它成功了，那种喧嚣，以及它所引发的所有投射等等。我觉得是的。其中也有很多基于恐惧的交流，也就是：“听着，如果你现在不这么做，以后就不会有了。如果你现在不这么做，以后没人会要你，或者如果你现在不工作以后就不会有工作，或者诸如此类，你知道的。”
And so you're like, oh my god, yeah, oh yeah, I don't want this to go away. So it's very, it can be kind of confusing what to do with that. And then of course I had spent 10 years not working at all. So you're like, yeah, yeah, I don't want, I mean, I don't want to go back to that, I guess. So I don't know. Yeah.
所以你会想：“哦天哪，对啊，哦对，我不想让这一切消失。”所以对于如何处理这种情况，你可能会感到很困惑。而且当然，我之前有10年根本没有工作。所以你会觉得，是的，是的，我不想，我是说，我不想再回到那种状态了，我想是的。所以我不清楚。是的。
I think for me, I would look back and just tell myself, I'm gonna be just fine. I think I was just worried that I wasn't going to be everything I was thought I should be and that I don't need to be anything other than just okay with myself. That's what I think. It's interesting how similar, sort of like success on somebody else's terms is not success and Success on your own terms doesn't have to look like Somebody else's or like the sort of consensus aspiration, right? It's like here and to be like I'm enough Basically, I'm enough who I am is enough what I want is enough
我想对我来说，我会回过头来告诉自己，我一切都会好起来的。我想我只是担心自己无法成为别人认为我应该成为的一切，而且我不需要成为别的什么，只要接受真实的自己就行了。这就是我的想法。有趣的是，别人的标准下的成功并不是真正的成功，而按你自己的标准成功，并不一定要看起来像别人的标准，或者像那种大众共同的渴望，对吧？就像在这里，觉得自己已经足够了，基本上，我足够了，我是谁就足够了，我想要的就足够了。
I think then that was something in that blog post that made an impression on me when I read it too Which is I think I don't remember the exact phrasing, it was basically like don't postpone joy, don't make a certain kind of professional success, a prerequisite for participating in your own life. That's my recollection. Yeah, well that was a thing when you're a struggling actor, especially you're like, well I can't go to my friends' wedding
我想那篇博客文章中有些内容也给我留下了深刻的印象，当我读到它的时候也是如此，我想我不记得具体怎么说的了，大意基本上是不要推迟快乐，不要把某种职业成功当作参与自己生活的先决条件。这是我的回忆。是的，好吧，当你在苦苦挣扎的时候这就是个问题，特别是你会觉得，嗯，我不能去朋友的婚礼，
because I might get a call back for a thing that I auditioned for, so I need to be here, or whatever it is. It's like, so I need to be here. Or whatever it is. It's like, well, I don't want to have a boyfriend because I don't want to be distracted. There's like all these limits and all these superstitions that you have as an artist because you are holding the art as the only thing, the only aspiration. And so what I found was, oh my gosh, the material and characters that I saw at that wedding
因为我可能会接到我试镜角色的回电通知，所以我需要留在这里，或者诸如此类的。这就好像，所以我得留在这里。或者别的什么。就像，嗯，我不想交男朋友，因为我不想分心。作为艺术家，你会有各种各样的限制和迷信，因为你把艺术当作唯一的事情，唯一的追求。所以我发现，天哪，我在那个婚礼上看到的素材和角色，
and the life experience I got from going to that thing is just going to feed my art. So it's like, you can't do art if you're just doing art. Right. I think you have to have a whole life in order to feed it. And an identity that's like weird, like self-esteem is a little bit more, like diversified. And others, if your whole worth originates from your ability to do this one thing And you're not doing that one thing and then you're kind of like Who are you?
以及我去那次活动获得的人生经验，只会为我的艺术提供养分。所以这就好像，如果你只是在做艺术，你就无法做好艺术。对的。我认为你必须拥有完整的生活来滋养它。还有一种奇怪的身份认同，比如自尊心稍微多元化一点。另外，如果你的全部价值都源于你做好这一件事的能力，而你又没有在做那件事，然后你就会有点像，你是谁？
Yeah, so like to have like if you're like, oh, yeah, I'm not just an actor. I'm someone's mom or I'm someone's right You know or I'm or not someone's I am a mom. I am a Bicycle enthusiast. I am a whatever, a volunteer. I, you know, then you, then it's not like, oh, when I'm auditioning for a part, I'm auditioning for myself worth. It's like, I'm just auditioning for the part. It's like, yeah, which is hard enough,
是的，所以就像如果有的话，如果你觉得，哦，对，我不只是个演员。我是某人的妈妈，或者我是某人的……对吧，你知道的，或者我不是某人的，我是一个妈妈。我是一个自行车爱好者。我是一个什么样的人，一个志愿者。我，你知道的，然后你，然后就不会变成那种，哦，当我在为一个角色试镜时，我是在为我自身的价值试镜。这就好像，我只是在为这个角色试镜。这就好比，是的，这已经够难了，
or daunting enough. That makes sense. That's beautiful. What about you, Zach? What would you go back and tell yourself? Get a basket at Walmart. If you're gonna be carrying that man, you can get a fires.
或者说已经够让人怯步了。这说得通。太美妙了。你呢，扎克？你会回到过去对当时的自己说些什么？在沃尔玛拿个购物篮吧。如果你要搬那个东西，你可以拿个加湿器。
I was basically like a walking close call video. I think what I tell myself, it's something similar. It's like, it's an interesting, I don't know, let me think for a second. I think, I think I probably would try to tell myself, and I probably wouldn't be able to hear it, but like, you don't need so much fear to protect you. You know what I mean?
我基本上就像一个行走的有惊无险的视频合集。我想我对自己的说的话，会是类似的事情。这是一种有趣的，我不知道，让我想一会儿。我想，我想我可能会试着告诉自己，虽然我可能当时听不进去，但就像：你不需要那么多的恐惧来保护你。你知道我的意思吗？
I think I used anxiety as a motivator and as a kind of protection where I sort of felt like, well, if I'm buying enough humidifiers and running my lines enough times and freaking out enough, then surely I'm doing everything in my power to do a good job. And if I don't do that, then I'm gonna be kind of culpable if it doesn't go well. I think if I could go back and say, like, when you're doing all
我觉得我把焦虑当作一种动力和一种保护，我当时隐约觉得，好吧，如果我买够了加湿器，把台词背了足够多的遍，并且足够抓狂，那么我肯定在尽我所能做好工作。如果我没有那样做，那么如果事情进展不顺，我就会有某种责任。我想如果我能回去说，就像，当你做所有
of that, it has more to do with like, it's more neurotic than artistic, you know what I mean? It's not that actually isn't serving. It's not really, hopefully it doesn't hurt the character or the work, but it's about something different. That's more about like your childhood than it is about the job you're doing job you're doing. And so I think if I could be like, don't mistake your neuroses for your artistic process. Like develop an artistic process independent of that as much as possible so that you're not just reenacting your own like, Cuckoo Bird's
这些事情的时候，它更多地与神经质有关，而不是与艺术有关，你知道我的意思吗？这其实并没有起到什么作用。它真的没有，希望它不会损害角色或工作，但它是关于别的事情的。这更多是关于你的童年，而不是你正在做的工作。所以我认为，如果我能像这样说：不要把你的神经质误认为是你的艺术创作过程。尽可能独立于此培养一个艺术创作过程，这样你就不会只是在工作中一遍又一遍地重演你自己的布谷鸟巢
story again and again at work. Like, tell a new story at work. Tell someone else's story at work. You know what I mean? I think you did hear it because I think just the fact that you recognize it that even though, I mean, I... Took a minute. Took a minute. Took a minute.
故事。比如，在工作中讲一个新的故事。在工作中讲别人的故事。你知道我的意思吗？我想你确实听进去了，因为我觉得仅仅是你意识到了这一点，尽管，我的意思是，我……花了一点时间。花了一点时间。花了一点时间。
What was your second question? Oh, yes. Second question is like, did you have a moment where you felt that kind of like, because so often I think when you get the thing that you want, it doesn't feel the way you thought it'd feel, blah, blah, blah, blah, like the behind the music, kind of like, I think, was there a moment
你的第二个问题是什么？哦，是的。第二个问题是，你有没有过这样一个时刻，你感受到了那种……因为很多时候我认为当你得到了你想要的东西时，感觉并不像你想的那样，诸如此类，像“音乐背后”那种感觉，我想，有没有一个时刻
where you had that kind of like shimmering magic feeling like where you're like looked around and you were like, ah, oh my God, like that moment where you're just like the sort of, the gift of it, where you felt like really holy present and able to just enjoy it. Like do you remember that either the first or the most intense version of that for you guys? The first one for me was when we were shooting the pilot on the first day and our director Ken Quapis said, I want to do 30 minutes of all of you all just working in this space.
让你有了那种波光粼粼的魔法般的感觉，你环顾四周，然后你会说，啊，天哪，就是那个时刻，你感觉到了那种天赋，你觉得自己真正全身心地在场，并且能够去享受它。比如你还记得你们当中谁的第一次或最强烈的那种感觉吗？对我和来说，第一次是我们在第一天拍摄试播集时，我们的导演肯·夸皮斯说，我想让你们所有人花30分钟在这个空间里工作。
Do your job and we're just going to come around and silently document you. Like a documentary, we're going to set the tone of this show. All right, go ahead. And I will never forget that 30 minutes of, first of all, there was silence because nobody really knew what to do. And then I feel like it was Phyllis picked up her phone and like hit some buttons and started
做好你们的工作，我们会在一旁默默地记录你们。就像拍纪录片一样，我们要定下这个节目的基调。好了，开始吧。我永远不会忘记那30分钟，首先，现场一片寂静，因为没有人真正知道该做什么。然后我觉得好像是菲利斯拿起电话，按了一些键，开始
a fake phone call. And then I started to hear buttons over the partition and accounting. And then everybody just started being their character and pretending like we worked at a paper company like all together. And I was like, the theater nerd in me was delighted and I thought I'm a part of something very special and I don't know what's gonna happen from here
假装打电话。然后我开始听到隔板那边会计部门传来的按键声。然后大家就开始扮演各自的角色，假装我们一起在一家造纸公司工作。然后我就觉得，我体内的戏剧书呆子狂喜不已，我想我正在参与一件非常特别的事情，我不知道接下来会发生什么，
but this is pretty dang cool. Wow. The sound. It does something like an orchestra tuning out like before. Yes, yeah. That's right. We go over about to play. Wow, that's so exciting.
但这绝对是酷毙了。哇。声音。它会产生某种效果，就像管弦乐队在演出前调音一样。是的，没错。没错。我们就快要演奏了。哇，太令人兴奋了。
I really felt that. Yeah. I mean, yeah, I loved that so much. For me, there's so many moments that felt like that, and they were almost always in the conference room, because we were all in there together, and we were all, each other's background, we were all in the moment,
我真的深有同感。是的。我是说，是的，我太喜欢那个了。对我来说，有很多瞬间都有这种感觉，而且它们几乎总是发生在会议室里，因为我们都在那里，而且我们都是彼此的背景，我们都融入了那个时刻，
and so many times I would have a minute where I was in the scene, but then I would step out of my body and I would just watch these amazing actors just fire off all these lines and everyone had their own character backstory and I just would be there in awe being like, this is so cool, this is so cool and I get to do this.
很多次我都会有那么一分钟，我置身于场景中，但随后我会灵魂出窍，只是看着这些优秀的演员们飙着这些台词，每个人都有自己的角色背景故事，我就会站在那里惊叹不已，心想：这太酷了，这太酷了，而且我竟然能做这件事。
And there were times my character didn't even have lines, but I just couldn't believe I was in the moment. There was a scene where Michael Scott is brainstorming animal hybrids and no one is saying anything. And Steve had his scripted lines, but then he started to just, they just let the camera roll and you just kept improvising animal hybrids. We all just had to sit there and look at him where he was like, head of an owl, body of a walrus, like whatever it was he was saying.
有时候我的角色甚至没有台词，但我就是不敢相信我身临其境。有这样一个场景，迈克尔·斯科特在集思广益想动物杂交种，而没有人说话。史蒂夫有他的剧本台词，但他随后开始，他们只是让摄像机开着，然后你一直即兴发挥动物杂交种。我们所有人就只能坐在那里看着他，他说着：猫头鹰的头，海象的身躯，无论他说的是什么。
And we were just all patiently looking at him. And then one by one people started to file out, like they were over it. And I just remember being like, this is the coolest, like this is the coolest. And I can't believe I get to do it. It's so sweet that in both your cases, it's sort of like, it's not the kind of grand slam scene for your character. It's just the scene where you're able to kind of
而我们大家只是耐心地看着他。然后大家一个接一个地开始鱼贯而出，就像他们受够了一样。我只记得当时的心情是：这是最酷的，这绝对是最酷的。而且我不敢相信我能参与其中。真令人暖心，在你们两人的经历中，这都有点像，这并不是针对你们角色的那种大满贯场景。这只是那种让你们能够
like behold the the majesty of this. Yeah. Working situation, right? Where you're like, it's about watching it and participating, but not in a way that foregrounds you. It's just a, I think like being a small part of a big thing is like the best feeling ever, right? Like feeling like you're part of a squad that like is, like that's such an exciting. So it's interesting, both of you guys, it was kind of like that feeling of like,
领略到这种工作氛围的宏大壮丽的场景，对吧？就像你觉得，这是关于观看和参与，但不是以凸显你自己的方式。这只是一种，我觉得成为宏大事物中的一小部分是史上最棒的感觉，对吧？就像感觉自己是一个团队的一部分，就像，那种感觉太让人兴奋了。所以很有趣，你们两个人的感觉都是，
oh, I'm part of this. When everyone starts improvising, the filing out and Michael's still doing his animals. Right. Or the everyone sort of slowly coming into the joining, yeah. Showing up for the first time in the fictional office in a way. It was such a smart thing that Ken did by doing that exercise with us because we didn't start with a scene.
哦，我是其中的一部分。当每个人都开始即兴发挥，大家鱼贯而出而迈克尔还在弄他的动物时。没错。或者每个人都慢慢加入进来，融入其中，是的。第一次以某种方式在虚构的办公室里出场。肯通过和我们做那个练习做了一件非常聪明的事，因为我们不是从一个场景开始的。
Like we didn't start with, okay, Steve Carell, our lead character, Michael Scott is going to do a scene. He made every single one of us equally important in the very first thing we shot. Wow. You know, nobody had any lines, but everyone was in character, and you really felt how, okay, so whatever scene is going on,
就像我们不是从“好吧，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔，我们的主角迈克尔·斯科特将要演一个场景”开始的。在我们拍摄的第一个镜头中，他让在场的每一个人都同样重要。哇。你知道的，没有人有台词，但每个人都在角色中，你真的能感受到，好吧，无论发生什么场景，
this is also always going on. So now we're gonna do a scene, but don't forget, you all are still working in this office, and you always have to be. It was really genius. That's cool. I think I missed that.
这其实也一直在发生。所以现在我们要拍一个场景了，但别忘了，你们所有人依然在这个办公室里工作，你们必须时刻保持状态。这真的是天才之举。太酷了。我想我漏掉了这个。
It was literally the first thing you shot. The very first thing. That's really it. Ever. The first time the camera's rolled, right? Yeah. I know. Just giving everyone a chance to kind of sort of a John did
这绝对是你们拍的第一个镜头。绝对是第一个镜头。真的是这样。有史以来。摄像机转动的第一次，对吧？是的。我知道。这只是给了每个人一个机会，有点像约翰为我做的那样，
for me when I did that little talking. Head where it was like, okay, just like, I mean, that's different because I was like talking, but I just mean like giving a lot of space. And it was, even that's costly. You're making a pilot, like time is money, everything, right? But just to be like, we got time, we got space, just exist. And I also think because it was Ken,
当我做那个小巧的采访镜头时，就像是，好吧，就像是——我的意思是那不同，因为我当时在说话，但我的意思是就像是留出了很大的空间。而且，即使那样也是有代价的。你在拍试播集，时间就是金钱，一切都是，对吧？但只是觉得——我们有时间，我们有空间，只要存在着就行。而且我也觉得因为那是肯，
the very first time we were all in a room and we were all gonna be these characters, no one yelled action. He just said, go ahead. Oh, that's nice. No one yelled action. He just said, go ahead. Oh, that's nice. Because that's Ken, right? So we just go ahead. So it was just like this very slow, comfortable, easing into this world. Did you ever see that John Cazal documentary? I know it was you, do you know John Cazal? Like I could play Fredo. He was like in five movies and they were all like
我们第一次聚在一个房间里，我们要成为这些角色，没有人喊“Action”。他只是说：“开始吧。”哦，太好了。没有人喊“Action”。他只是说：“开始吧。”哦，太好了。因为那是肯，对吧？所以我们就“开始吧”。所以这就像是非常缓慢、舒服地、逐渐进入这个世界。你见过那部关于约翰·卡扎尔的纪录片吗？我知道是你，你知道约翰·卡扎尔吗？就像我能演弗雷多。他演过五部电影，而且全都是
the, but he was like the deer hunter, Godfather wanted to the conversation. He died when he was a young man, but they made a documentary about him because he did these like incredible movies and that's it. He just did these and then theater and stuff. But Al Pacino, he used to talk day after noon, Al Pacino, until these stories where they be like shooting on film and they would start rolling and Al Pacino would be all kind of coiled up and do his line. And he said this guy, the junk saw,
那种，但他就像《猎鹿人》、《教父1至2》里的对话。他在很年轻的时候就去世了，但他们为他拍了一部纪录片，因为他拍了这些不可思议的电影，仅此而已。他只是拍了这些，然后还有戏剧什么的。但阿尔·帕西诺，他经常在下午的时候谈论，阿尔·帕西诺，直到这些故事，他们会在胶片上拍摄，然后他们开始转动摄像机，阿尔·帕西诺会全身紧绷，准备说他的台词。他说这家伙，约翰·卡扎尔，
just be like, what'd you do this weekend now? And he'd hear the film moving through the camera and he'd be like, I don't know, I like made dinner with my girlfriend on Saturday. Oh yeah, what'd you make? Oh, we made a rigatoni and, you know, oh yeah, what'd you do after that? And like just talk until like,
就会说：“你这周末干嘛了，阿尔？”然后他听到胶片在摄像机里移动的声音，他就会说：“我不知道，我周六和我女朋友一起做了晚饭。”“哦是吗，你做了什么？”“哦，我们做了意大利通心粉，你知道的。”“哦是吗，你之后又干嘛了？”然后就这样一直聊，直到……
how much you know, settle down. And then he'd just say like the first line of the scene where it's like, he would just sort of get them in a place of like, we're just here, we're just here with each other and then slowly sort of introduce the dialogue which is like such a policy-crazy thing to do. Yeah.
你知道的，情绪平静下来。然后他就会说出场景的第一句台词，就像是，他会让他们进入这样一种状态：我们就在这里，我们彼此陪伴，然后慢慢地引入对话，这真是一件非常帕西诺风格的事情。是的。
I mean like 35 millimeter film is running through a camera, but I just was like, it sounds like in a version of that, right? Where it's like, go ahead. Yeah, go ahead. It's not ready, say, go. Get your adding machine a few times. Yeah, that's nice. Yeah.
我的意思是，就像35毫米胶片在摄像机里运行，但我只是觉得，听起来像是其中的一种版本，对吧？就像是：开始吧。是的，开始吧。按几下你的加法器。是的，太好了。是的。
I feel bad. I feel like I've now just standing or okay. I love this so much. It's just made my heart so happy. Me too. Yeah. And I really, yeah, I can't say it enough. Like, it's a real talent I don't have, which
我感觉很糟。我感觉我现在只是站在那里，或者……好吧。我太喜欢这个了。这让我的心感到无比幸福。我也是。是的。而且我真的，是的，我怎么说都不够。就像，我没有的一个真正的天赋，
is like to maintain. Do you ever see those Richard Link later, the before sunset, before sunrise? I love those movies. But that's sometimes what shooting feels like to me, where it's this very discreet, specific experience of like real big emotion, intimacy, connection. And then you're off to your lives and you don't, to me it often feels that way. It's like it's like this amazing one night stand or something except it happened to be a two year stand. But and so I feel like I've kind of lost touch
那就是保持联系。你见过理查德·林克莱特的《爱在黎明破晓前》、《爱在日落黄昏时》吗？我太喜欢那些电影了。但有时拍摄给我的感觉就是那样，它是一种非常私密、具体的体验，有着巨大的真实情感、亲密感、连接。然后你就回归生活，你不会……对我来说，这种感觉经常出现。这就像是一夜情或者别的什么，只不过碰巧维持了两年。但是，所以我觉得我有点失去了
with you guys and this larger squad, but I can just never say enough how much it meant that everyone was so kind. I just, in a way that you guys did to gain nothing from that. I had nothing to offer you. And in a way, I could have been either in your, like, I could have been a problem in that it's like another mouth to feed on this big show, like, but that was not how I was receiving that really set the
和你们以及这个庞大团队的联系，但我永远无法表达足够的感激，感谢每个人都如此友善。我只是觉得，在你们当时根本无利可图的情况下。我没有什么可以提供给你们的。从某种程度上讲，我本来可能会成为你们的负担，就好像这是这个大节目中又要多一张要喂养的嘴一样，但这不是我当时的感受，这真的为我
tone for the rest of my working life out thus far. And so I just, yeah, I don't know. I just want it. I felt when you guys kindly invited me on, I was like, I want to say to people, I want people who like the show to know how kind the people who worked on the show were and are, you know. You know, I think we were happy. Exactly. We were a happy cast, we were a happy crew, and we just knew like there's enough to go around for everyone. There just is. There always is. In good comedy and good art, you do not need to be stingy.
迄今为止的职业生涯定下了基调。所以，是的，我不知道。我只是想要。当你们好心邀请我来的时候，我觉得：我想告诉大家，我想让喜欢这个节目的人知道，曾经参与这个节目的人是多么的善良，现在也依然如此，你知道的。你知道的，我想我们当时很开心。没错。我们是一个快乐的演员阵容，我们是一个快乐的剧组，我们只是知道，每个人都有足够的份额。本来就是这样。一直都是。在好的喜剧和好的艺术中，你不需要小气。
You know. It's a collective. It is. And and it was an abundant universe and I think we all looked at it that way. We always felt like we won the lottery. We always talk about that and I think everyone felt that way. So why not share it? A lot of lottery winners hire like private security and like a bunch of doberman, some shit. You guys really, you know, you guys are like the good lottery winners. Yeah. Zach, thank you so much for coming on.
你知道的。这是一个集体。确实如此。而且这是一个资源丰富的宇宙，我想我们都是这样看待它的。我们总觉得自己中了彩票。我们总是谈论这个，我想每个人都有这种感觉。那为什么不分享呢？很多中彩票的人会雇佣私人保安和一群杜宾犬什么的。你们真的，你知道的，你们就像是那种幸运的中彩票的人。是的。扎克，非常感谢你来到这里。
Thank you for having me. It was really fun. What are you doing now that we can tell people about? I'm making the stop motion show that actually Greg Daniels is, like, he's his company, but it is one of the producers on. It's a stop motion show about an NPR host. So I'm doing that right now and that'll come out. Are you the voice of the NPR host?
谢谢你们邀请我。真的很有趣。你现在在做什么我们可以告诉大家的节目？我在制作一部定格动画秀，实际上格雷格·丹尼尔斯是，就像，那是他的公司，但他是制片人之一。这是一部关于NPR主持人的定格动画秀。所以我现在在做这个，它会播出的。你是NPR主持人的配音吗？
Yeah. Amazing. You'll have to let us know when it comes out and where people can find it and we're going to share it. Oh, that's so sweet. Yeah. But anyway, thanks for having me on this really a treat. It's so nice to reconnect with you guys. I love to see you. Love you, Zach. Yeah, you too. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jennifer
是的。太棒了。节目上映以及大家能在哪里找到它时，一定要告诉我们，我们会分享的。哦，太贴心了。对。不管怎样，谢谢你们邀请我，这真是一次难得的享受。能和你们重新联系真是太好了。很高兴见到你们。爱你，扎克。是的，我也是。谢谢你们收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf制作，詹妮弗
Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our in-studio engineer is Sam Keeper. Our editing and mixing engineer is Jordan Duffy, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbico. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
费舍尔和安吉拉·金西。我们的高级制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的驻场录音师是萨姆·基珀。我们的剪辑和混音师是乔丹·达菲，我们的助理制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡皮树》。[♪ 片尾曲播放中 [♪ 本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。